what was your first professional
directing job
first professional directing job was
when i took a short film i had directed
when i was 22
my first film shot on film and
i had a choice to make uh between
take that film and try to raise money
and try to write a script and be an
indie filmmaker or to go into
commercials and advertising
so i chose the latter and i went into
advertising
like some of my heroes ridley scott tur
sam tony scott david fincher
so i took that film into several ad
agencies
and was offered a job right away
and and then they said
we want you to shoot something on spec
for us
because shooting your own film and
shooting a commercial
is completely different when it comes to
parameters for time and
budget and so forth and i got offered a
script for a black and white surf
style uh 16 millimeter um
surf like it was sort of like in the
vein of the malloy brothers jack johnson
you know this sort of like surf awesome
guitar
commercial for this taco brand and um
so i shot it on film shot on black and
white reversal which they didn't want me
to do i wanted to shoot on color
and i wanted to do change the color in
the di and i
insisted on black and white reversal and
we shot it
and the client loved it it was a look
they didn't anticipate
had kind of a it had kind of a
an endless summer style to it but it was
very very very high contrast
so it felt very portrait-esque with
these beautiful people eating burritos
oh wow that's awesome and they really
dug it and uh
so i got known as the guy who is a
little analog
you know that was like right when red
camera was taking off
and i kept pushing analog the whole time
i kept wanting to shoot on film
um because we were gonna be seeing
everything in digital
i wanted to go the other way so that
when you saw my work or the work of that
agency
that it would pop you know come out of
people
so yeah you said you were 22 22.
yeah so this was in the washington area
yeah yeah i shopped my reel
which was a five-minute uh boxing
prize fighter um short film called in
the corner
which no one will ever get to see uh
i shopped at around seattle and portland
and a couple of other small markets i
knew that i wanted to stay in the
pacific northwest i didn't want to go to
la yet
and so yeah i shopped at i
think three or four agencies and two of
them were really interested
and then i went with the one that had
the biggest accounts
because i wanted to work on big
commercials from day one
yeah 22. how does a 22 year old convince
an ad agency executive to use film
and and do it sort of more i
i did a lot of homework before my first
meeting so those pitch meetings
uh which took some time to get i
called around and i figured out who the
creative directors were
i looked at their work i looked at who
was doing stuff that was very trendy
and and sort of just what you would
expect from an ad agency and then i
looked at cds work that it was really
provocative or
old school or they were going for the
kernel of an idea that
that maybe the audience or the consumer
wasn't expecting
with some success and some failure you
know you look at ad campaigns and you're
like that was a great idea
or that was great execution and a
terrible idea and um
so i was really looking for agencies
that did
really interesting stuff and fortunately
the the creative director that i worked
with
um or create chief creative officer
because he was the
honcho he had a passion for film
and he had a passion for aero morris
and he had a passion for scorsese and
he liked these eccentric pictures that
other people would never know and i knew
what they were
and so when i sat down with this
particular individual
and i showed him my film he said oh you
shot on 16. i said no i shot on super 16
and i started talking about film stocks
and he knew some of that but he didn't
know all of it but he was turned on
because he was like
this kid which i was a kid um
wants to be um he wants to go after
things like a filmmaker
not like um not like a copywriter
or whatnot and um so we ended up
talking about films like the last waltz
right or
um endless summer came up of course
tokyo olympiad which is a really awesome
criterion documentary about the tokyo
olympics where they
i think it's like 10 or 12 filmmakers
they hired different filmmakers
and each filmmaker shot different events
differently
so some shot video some shot eight mill
some shot 35 millimeter
and then they cut it all together in a
documentary that that actually was
primary topic of our first interview we
talked about this
very obscure documentary that only
cinephiles really know about and um
and uh and then we ended up nerding out
on film stock and so he
from day one he was very um supportive
of trying to get that across the line um
with all the clients
and some of them said no um so then he
was really supportive of
if we weren't gonna shoot film and we
were going to go digital that we studied
it you know he gave me this bandwidth
like time and some resources to say hey
we're not shooting film what should we
shoot on you know
and uh it was um
you know the advertising industry paid
for me to go to film school
do you remember how much you were paid
for this first directing gig
yeah i had a very interesting um role
at that agency because they didn't hire
me freelance to direct
they hired me to direct a lot of their
stuff
so i kind of had a contract right away
which is very unusual
usually you're freelance director and
you pick up this and you pick up that
and i think because of this creative
relationship that i had right away
with this creative executive that he
really wanted that he wanted like oh hey
if you're going to direct or dp what
we're doing
i want you to do all of our stuff so all
of our stuff has a brand
right because one of the ways things
become really inefficient
in commercial production until you get
to a certain level
when you're paying for a name or you're
paying for an established
director that has a brand that brings
gravitas to a project
but everything else is has an
inefficiency to the fact that
you know you build the whole production
team and then the next
project you change it all again and the
next project you change it all again
um and that can be beneficial for
multiple clients of course but
this particular agency's size had some
big accounts but not a lot and so
they uh they thought it was really
beneficial to hire me and put me on
salary so
and i think i made 42 000 a year
and then within about a year i sat them
down and asked for
a massive race so
how long did you end up staying with
this just under three years
yeah yeah it was very uh
i came right in at the time
when they had an nfl team account
and i got to work on that account at a
high level
and that that team went to the super
bowl
and our work was up on jumbotrons and
they were using our work to do big
advice and so it was kind of like
it was kind of like being on top of the
wave
before it rises you know so it was a
timing thing
um but but getting in that door was
about
a a collaborative passion for
film and movies and talking
um uh talking at length i mean we would
go
on location in new york or montreal and
we'd be in the car for hours
this uh creative director and i or we'd
be on flights
and we would just start talking about
movies and so we had this
we were both always kind of in agreement
secretly that
every commercial could be a film and
that stuck with me that sort of
rebellion you know because the client
wants you to photograph their chicken
or their burrito or something and we
wanted to tell a story
about why people even care about this
brand and um
that that stayed with me through all of
my advertising career because
i always was pushing back on
aesthetics like what it should look like
or on the fact that it needs to have a
story
or people don't care and sometimes when
you're in a room full of marketing
people they really don't
care about your point of view about that
so um
so yeah i stayed there for um a few
years
and then i moved on is there a style to
finesse that especially because
you might have been one of the youngest
people in the room i'm just assuming i
was for a while yeah
i was usually the youngest which means i
tried not to say much
unless i felt really i really wanted to
listen i really wanted to learn
i didn't know the advertising world at
all you know
and i didn't presume to know
how a client gives an agency a million
dollars to shoot
an ad campaign like i'm like i don't
know how that happens and how do they
siphon off a half a million of that to
do a tv spot
campaign right or whatever the budget is
so
it was a lot of shutting up paying
attention
um and so
the finesse or the
negotiation between an agency and a
client
is each one of those relationships is
very unique right because you have some
clients who will talk to the creative
team at an agency and they'll say
we trust you go for it right
that's the optimal situation and then
you'll have a pessimistic situation
which is
a client that's like we need close-ups
of the mop
or the chicken or the
sport cleat or whatever it is and you'll
say well who's
you know who's holding the burrito where
are they
and how did they get there and why are
they there and that's the story of that
ad right and there are some clients that
are um
not interested not interested they're
interested in thinking that the reason
why people buy things
is because they're robots and they're
not
people buy things because they decided
to
accept your invitation so and i think
advertising
is an invitation you can make an
invitation for people and
a lot of people um i mean advertising
shifted a lot since i was 22.
um and it's very there's a lot of things
overall in the market that are way more
beautiful or the production value of
things is better
but the storytelling is the same it's
still very a to z
on one side you have absolutely
excellent storytelling
that happens to be about a brand right
and then on the other end you have like
um you know a detergent ad that's just
telling you how
clean your socks are gonna be so yeah i
don't know
much about the nuance of actually
convincing someone
to want to shoot my idea
like i actually don't know how to do it
exactly
i think what i learned over time was you
get to know
the client really well and you
work on their trust and they'll trust
you more and more
and then if something's not successful
you'll
figure that out and they'll say hey your
big idea didn't work
and i've had really big advertising
ideas that didn't work
ideas that um
that no one believed in but me and some
other people and it got
shot and it got done in one awards and
whatever and um so
i always paid really close attention to
the trust level between
the agency and the client and how to
you know when the trust is right you go
okay cool
then we can do this did you think about
if you hadn't done your research and
gone for that interview
where your career would be no never
because that's just how i am
you know um when i was
14 i thought i wanted to be a fashion
photographer
so i shot a lot of photography and
developed my own film
and learned how to use a lot of
different kinds of cameras and
work in the dark room and there was a
photographer in the town that i
lived in and grew up in that was really
well known very very highly known guy
and his name is paul boyer and he did a
book
called 100 over 100 where he went around
the world and met with a hundred people
who were
over 100 and photographed them in these
beautiful portraits
and did a book and it's incredible book
and it had just come out
you know right about that time when i
was about 13 or 14.
and i did a lot of research on him and
ended up knocking on the door of his
studio and after
a few um
knocks uh i met with him and
you know i just wanted to talk to him
for like you know and he said okay you
can talk to me for a half hour
and i remember it very very well
my i couldn't drive my mother took me to
this guy's like huge
photo studio on the corner of a city
block and that
was massive and um
she says okay i'll be out in a half hour
and i would start i talked to him for
like three hours you know
and so the research thing started
then which was like if i really cared
about something i wanted to learn about
it and also
accept the humility of like this is my
this is my knowledge line
this is where it is so the next person
i'm gonna learn from
has to be great right and um
so that three-hour conversation turned
into me working for him for three years
yeah and i went to italy with him to do
a book
and um he taught me everything
i ever could imagine about
every format of photography and i was
very patient
and he was very like um uh
he had daughters he didn't have a son so
we had a very we had a very like
we weren't father and son at all but we
were we really cared about each other
and he
took me under his wing in a way that
wasn't like a regular like assistant
he was like it reminds me of like the
way a painter
would have an apprentice in like
renaissance you know florence
where they say hey you earned this spot
now i'm going to um
teach you everything i know but i'm
going to hold you accountable to the
knowledge
and he would he he for example
he wouldn't let me
shoot a single frame of medium format
film for like a year uh he would let me
load his hasselblads he taught me how to
do it
basically blindfolded like and but he
said you know you have to earn every
shot
you have to earn every frame and every
frame matters and um
so that taught me a lot i felt i felt
this sense of reward
that i had studied him and then when i
met him i had enough information to
sort of represent myself you know be
like i'm serious man i'm serious
about this and i'm 14.
and uh he took a sh took a shot on me
you know with with me working with him
and changed my life forever
uh but it also taught me that that
research is necessary if you want to do
anything else
and uh so i don't think about
if i wouldn't have studied the people i
wanted to present my
short film to because that was just
the way i was and the way i am now you
know
i read about you guys before i got here
right all lies
um so yeah no i don't really think about
that
but anyway it's a good question it's a
great question well thank you
yeah it's a time machine question right
what the
you know what if i'm just glad i'm not a
lawyer
did you that was actually my next
question so not were you
planning to go to law school but you
knew you loved
the image still image moving image
whatever yeah
did you it seems like you kind of have
always known what you've wanted to do
since you were a young age
um i think that you mean to be a
director film director
or something in terms of you want to be
behind a camera yeah
creating something uh i did i i did i
was very resolute
like you know uh until i was in my
sort of like mid-teens or whatever you
know and i i was on a mock trial team
which is like a fake legal team and you
study a brief and you study a case and
all this and i was really passionate
about the law
and when i went to university i studied
acting
and i focused on japanese acting and
some
russian acting stanislavski technique
but then i also studied international
law
and i kind of had for probably about
i don't know five or five five years six
years i had
sort of two mistresses do you know what
i mean i was like i really love
film and i love photography but it
hadn't yet
really turned into directing
right it was a it was being a
photographer right
and i looked at the landscape of how you
become a
photographer and i looked at the
landscape of
of what really turned me on and there
was this combination that started to
evolve which was photography and acting
okay great that's that's film right and
then i started writing
in my late teens um you know
sketches short films and then
when i was in acting school it started
to evolve that
there's an aspect of the theater that i
after having done a lot of theater and
being super passionate about shakespeare
and
all that i actually had an experience on
stage once where i became
very detached from being on stage i was
like i don't want to do this anymore
and um and about three months later
i i began planning that first short film
that boxing
movie because i said this passion for
the theater that's been there since i
was 15.
it six years later five six years later
is starting to
crumble so is it crumbling because it's
dying and it needs to die and sometimes
passions need to die or is it
transforming to something else and it
was definitely transforming into
oh i want to be able to control this
actor or that actor or this part of the
scene
and theater's alive
so it's not that so film is that motion
is that
making movies is controlling every
aspect you can
and then building it and cutting it and
building a rhythm and editorial
where it's alive right but it's it's
like
filmmaking is the greatest illusion ever
and it's the best of all
art forms in my opinion because it's a
convergence of all of them
so um so it was very odd because i shot
a couple of shorts in high school
that were basically like my way of
talking out
talking my way out of a test you know
the teacher's like
we're going to do a test on the 20s and
i said i'll make a short film about a
speakeasy during prohibition and she's
like i don't know how you're going to
get into a bar
but okay and i did and we shot it and it
was very like
again no one will ever ever see that um
but so it was interesting it was like it
was it was not
spielberg oriented or um some other
directors who like you know
like jj abrams who like shot super eight
film when he was like
eight and he's always gonna be a
director it was
a more
um it was much more of a journey
where i think it's like when you're
climbing
a mountain or you know or you're in a
sailboat or something like that and you
say i'm going to go there i'm definitely
going there
and as you get closer you look
beyond where you thought you were going
to go
and you sort of trust um
your own judgment and the universe and
then
you really take advantage of opportunity
you know when someone presents an
opportunity
you go yeah i want to do that and i
would never have thought
i would never have thought at the end of
university that i would have
been a commercial director like six
months later like
never but then it happened and then it
was like yes this is so this is magical
this is it
you know and um so
i wouldn't presume to say that i always
had this master plan
because i didn't and um
i trusted where things were taking me
and then when it clicked though oh that
was amazing
you know when i shot that first um when
i shot that first short film
i remember um we were shooting a fight
sequence
overcranked um on 16 mil
i had all these actors i had gone to
acting school with who were
working for sandwiches right and you
know we had like one
overhead like kino and um
i remember shooting these first few
reels of film
and then we took them to the lab and
then we got them back
and i i um i remember this
uh sense of
um watching uh
like uh in the film the prestige he
talks about that there's three parts of
a magic trick and the third part is
called the prestige it's when you
they blow your mind right and i remember
having that feeling of
this is this is it this is all those
things that have come together
uh this is acting this is writing this
is
photography and
also from having traveled having had the
opportunity to travel a lot when i was
younger and
and go to galleries and see paintings of
beautiful work
that some were singed into my memory
it was this um
catharsis birth you know
chrysalis whatever you want to call it
it was just this moment of
absolute connection and everything made
sense
um and that began a very hard road
to now
your love for justice your love for the
law i still love it
i still love it a lot i read a lot about
international law
i wanted to when i was studying
i wanted to i was very interested in
that there's this assumption when you
grow up in america
if you have certain opportunities which
i did and you grow up in a certain sort
of like socio-economic demographic and
whatnot
where you go oh you know every other
nation in the world
has our kind of law enforcement and our
kind of democracy
and which is super naive and not true
and as all of that becomes
very clear there's this
huge canyon between
our legal system which is broken and
it's working the best it can
and a country that has no legal system
zero and
it's just free-for-all and it's pure
crime or
we would define it as that with our
legal system and so
i was always interested in right and
wrong i was interested in what people
are capable of i was interested in
big cases like murder capital murder
i wasn't interested in why someone
steals a car i was interested in
psychology of the law
and i was interested in the the
presumption of innocence which isn't
true
you know we say you're presumed innocent
until proven guilty
and that's not true um especially it's
not true
if you're not rich and
so what turned me on the most was
uh international law because that's
where the most work needs to be done
as far as people being accountable for
crimes i studied a lot of war crimes
but i also realized something that um
in my like fixation on the legal process
i was very interested in juries i was
very interested in
um how an attorney communicates
with people who don't know anything
about a case
which is storytelling and i remember
having a really interesting conversation
with a judge once
a powerful guy in washington state and
we were talking about my future and uh
i said i think i was a junior in college
and uh
said hey you know i think i'm gonna take
lsats and i'm gonna give this go
and he talked me out of it and yeah he
was like
he said i don't think that you actually
love the law and i don't think you
actually want to be an attorney
and this is a guy who was mentored since
i was like
16 or something in high school so you
know five years or whatever it was
and he said no i don't think he should
do it and i said why not he said i think
you
like i think you like telling the jury
the story of the crime
i think you like standing up there and
um
you know being um
the you know tom cruise and a few good
man right or atticus
or um or the firm
or the firm uh or mcconaughey hand a
time to kill
or or you know what not and um
those crime are sorry those those trial
dramas that were
great films uh with great performances
because he saw me in a courtroom doing
mock trial and he said i think that you
like performing
more than you really like sitting down
and reading a
book of jurisprudence and looking at
um looking at case law i don't think
you're passionate about that and he said
if you're a really great attorney
you have to be passionate about that
there's a history side to the legal
system that you have to be really
um interested in and i i i told him the
truth i was like i'm not interested in
that i'm interested in convincing these
convincing these people that this person
is guilty or not guilty or whatever
and um he said well you're proving my
point and you
you shouldn't do this then because
that's not ethical
because that's not a good enough reason
to go through law school
or to go through whatever the um
you know whatever the you know whether
it's public practice or whether it's
private practice you know you're either
going to be working for a gigantic firm
and toe on the line
or you're going to be
learning about the politics of the inner
workings of a
of a da's office or something and he's
like you know when it's dark and the
demons come
you have to be passionate about the law
and you're not
you're passionate about telling the
story and
so that sent my that sent my
pursuit of justice into a tailspin
because i felt like i felt like i hadn't
been telling myself the truth
about why i had been pursuing that um
and then i was in a couple of plays that
dealt with the law
and it kind of solidified it it was like
oh man this guy's super right
i like telling this story i don't you
know i don't care about this actual
trial
i care about the experience for the
audience and so
so yeah so by the time i um
decided to make a short film my
flame for being an attorney had
gone out what about uh doing a
documentary
on a case um i
have i don't have a strong
affinity for documentaries
i've watched a number of them i've
watched a number of documentaries
most documentaries that i've seen have
been recommended to me to see
i don't go out i don't go documentary
film festivals i don't
i don't search through you know
documentary lists and look
for docs um there's something about that
that's super true and real and beautiful
and human that's not manipulated i mean
some documentaries are manipulated but
or they have a voice they're trying to
have a voice
that is trying to stay as true in the
wind
as possible um but i
far prefer the beauty of
and the creation of something original
and telling a story
that hasn't been told before if you
watch a documentary you know the end
like mostly mostly like oh it's about
this and that's what that's about and
that's what happened right
like if a documentary was about kennedy
assassination you're like i wonder what
that's about right
as opposed to sitting down in the dark
with a film maybe you've only seen a
trailer for or maybe you've only seen a
press junket thing for
and time traveling you know
you sit in a dark room and everything
goes dark
and you go somewhere else you know one
of the one of the earliest films
that i um
that stayed like in my heart and my soul
until today
um and will continue to is the film ask
the mohicans
and i saw that film my dad we went twice
and that's truly time travel like you go
into that film
um and you know i think i saw that in 93
or something so i was young and
right away michael mann puts on screen
i think it says 1777
or 1778 and it has this you know
beautiful gorgeous score and then it
starts in the blue mountains and you're
like
i am there um
and i'm super passionate about telling a
story that's
not true and a documentary is generally
true
and um i am really passionate about
creating an illusion
you know of of um
of something from nothing and uh
so yeah that's why i didn't make a
documentary about the law but there's
some really awesome ones that i like a
lot
but i have friends who are like super
keen on docs
and i kind of i kind of rely on them
i'll be like hey man what's super good
and then they tell me what to watch um
but i
i would prefer to watch something else
that is going to
take me into a world i've never been to
before
how does an american director end up in
new zealand
i was the creative director for tequila
brand um
in my mid to late 20s and
i had been working with the team that
designed the bottle
and designed the logo and the branding
and the identity
and had done beautiful work just
just extraordinary work and this was a
design agency in new zealand
i became very close with a guy named
dave quinlan and
we became buddies he became like my kiwi
friend we would skype
and you know we would talk in meetings
between agencies
but then we would like see how each
other's families are doing and so forth
and i had made i left that agency
and his design firm still had the
account and
i came to la and i was working in la and
i was shooting commercials in la
i was i was writing a lot here and um
i wasn't feeling the town the town's
vibe was not my jam
and it was like um uh i think it was
kind of like
it was not anything harsh you know
people have said really harsh things
about la or not digging it but like
for me it was sort of i went to
a restaurant or i went to a film or i
went to a
concert and in my mind i was going to go
to this one kind of restaurant or this
one kind of concert it was one kind of
film
and then when i got to la the experience
was different
it was i'm not talking about restaurants
i'm talking about metaphors where it's
like i heard like it was not the same
vibe i thought it was gonna be
it just wasn't it just wasn't clicking
it you know
i met some great people here i still
have those friends are still friends
today
um but the town itself the the energy of
the town
without it being woo sounding woo-woo
it's like it just wasn't like filling my
soul
and i also came from
like i've talked about with photographer
advertising agency etc
i had come from an environment where i
had reached out to mentors i had reached
out to people way better at what i
wanted to do
than than i was at the stage i was at
and i didn't find any of that in la i
found a sense of
i found a sense of unimportance
i found a sense of i'm one of a million
who wants to fulfill a dream and it was
never it's not a dream people say that
to me oh you fulfilled your dream and
i'm like
it's just work this is building the next
you know bigger project it's not like
i'm sitting around rubbing a lamp
right and waiting for a dream to come
true so when i was in la i
expressed that to my friends in new
zealand and i said man this town is not
my jam
you know it's not and and i was working
with some really creative people
doing some great work but you know
there's a
when you make films or commercials like
it's family
it's really a tight group of people and
i just wasn't finding my rhythm like
they had found their rhythm
right they had found the neighborhood
they wanted to live in they had found
the place they were going to send their
kids to school they had found
their roots um i didn't find that
in los angeles when i came here and
lived here and worked here
i was fortunate to work here i know a
lot of people who come here and nothing
happens
so that was wonderful but my connection
with new zealand stayed
true and robust and so that firm
invited me down to work on the tequila
account
and to just sort of hang out in new
zealand and i
i shot uh i shot a couple of projects
that were right up until i was gonna fly
out i remember leaving the set
over in the mountains i was on the set
in the mountains at this waterfall and i
left got in my car and drove to lax
and flew to new zealand and uh
uh which is a very la moment you know i
just got offsetting
a plane um
and got off the plane
and fell in love with the landscape
driving from auckland airport into
auckland city
went into the city it felt it felt a
little bit parallel
to the waterfront of seattle which was
home it felt
it was so clean and beautiful um
and i i went in may which is essentially
their fall
you know um sort of their like october
november
weather um and i stayed there for three
weeks and by the end of three weeks
we went from all sort of hanging out as
buddies
to we had a business plan a business
model an agency we were going to run
and a name and all that and i
left and came back here and sort of put
some of the stuff i was doing here on
hold
and then for about a year i started
going
doing i started commuting
from new zealand to us to from new
zealand to los
angeles so i would go down to new
zealand for like eight weeks
eight or ten weeks and then i would come
back to los angeles
we were shooting work in la we were
shooting work in austin
um a little bit in new york and
we had clients all over the place and
that opportunity in new zealand
started to gain momentum
with the fact that um the
relationships that i couldn't really
build very tightly in los angeles just
due to not having the vibe
i started to build in new zealand you
know like i built a really great
relationship with the camera house there
i built a really great relationship with
a series of producers
some of the production companies there
are far more accessible
than they are in los angeles you know
like to talk to
a studio head here you gotta like kill
six people and you still might not get a
meeting
um i'm joking about that uh but in new
zealand you like send the guy an email
or the gal an email and you say i'm this
person this is my work
i'd like to meet uh and they would be
like alright cool
because it's a smaller community and
they're not used to people
only coming and asking for things
they're used to people coming and saying
oh yeah mate let's go
go to the pub and get a beer so i
started to really understand the film
industry
from i met with people at village
roadshow i met with people at wetta i
i sort of really understand the film
industry not from a hollywood
perspective
but from that perspective which is the
same because they made the same product
that was going into hollywood and being
sold they had deals with studios right
and uh universal is big down there
and so
so new zealand turned into a big robust
advertising factory of creative as well
so as the chief creative officer of that
agency
i wrote and directed every commercial we
did
so it was it was again this um
it was a craftsman opportunity more than
i didn't want to just leave la that
wasn't the point
the point was i'm going to go and shoot
a ton of ads i'm going to work a lot and
i'm going to
develop my craft more and also
i wrote five feature scripts when i was
there
in about
uh in just under three years you know so
it was an opportunity to just like get
in the
zone so yeah that's how an american
ended up in new zealand
and it was it was extraordinary it
changed my life forever
having been in advertising having been
around the marketing world
working for this tequila company sure
been in la
traveled do you think a filmmaker should
have their own
marketing plan like their own brand
not just for their films but for them
100 100 um
filmmakers need to think about marketing
they need to think about the brand of
their product
they need to think about who's going to
buy their product
who's going to watch their movie now
there's this
relationship that you have to build and
it doesn't come right away because
if you've never marketed anything before
it's like two different parts of your
brain
right you have to look at it like why
would someone choose to watch my film
just swiping through itunes or or even
at a marquee in a cinema
why are they gonna watch your film it's
very hard to answer that question
for for yourself if you have no practice
marketing anything
because you're going to be very
subjective about your work
it's art it's precious it's
yours there's a there's a possession and
a permission to it that you know people
um at different experience levels they
have different levels of control over
the way they hold what they make
and it's very difficult to step outside
that ownership
of your work and look at it objectively
and be like does someone even want to
watch this right
and so i think if filmmakers
expose themselves to marketing plans and
marketing objectives
it's not about that they're gonna become
a marketing executive
right and they're suddenly gonna um
they're suddenly gonna become jaded and
they're not gonna care about the passion
of filmmaking
um and that's probably the worry they're
like i don't wanna study marketing
because it'll take away
all of the magic right but
then you're also super naive about the
fact that you're not preparing yourself
for success because if you work super
hard and you stay
really incubated and you know nothing
about who's going to participate with
your brand
or your film you will probably only get
to make one
because it won't be successful you won't
have resources or
if you have investors they'll feel like
nobody saw the film it'll lose money
so it's kind of uh
there needs to be a relationship where
you become familiar with
the dance between i have to look
objectively
at the work because i am
making it for an audience which leads me
to my next point i guess which is
eventually you have to acknowledge an
audience
and i know people who don't i know
people who are artists visual artists
true and true
i know people who are screenwriters who
don't care about
[Music]
getting coverage or they don't care
about letting somebody else read their
material
who may be objective or who may be
critical
and that's great that's a hobby that's a
hobby that's not a professional
a professional understands the industry
a professional understands that it's a
marketplace
someone wants what you made or they
don't and
if you want to have a career i
suggest that if people are really
unfamiliar with branding and marketing
they try to understand it at least that
doesn't mean they need to have a
relationship doesn't mean they need to
go shoot ads
but if they don't understand it then
they are um cheating themselves out of
the possibility of doing more work and
so i think it's super critical um i
guess the other thing i'd say is that
one of the things that's happened for me
transitioning from advertising to
uh features was that relationship with
an audience
you know i had opportunities
for lack of a better i had opportunities
for lack of a better phrase where i
could get away with it
i could get away with pitching to a
client a highly artistic vision
for a commercial and they loved the idea
so much
that whether it sold a lot more watches
or athletic jackets or
motorcycles they loved the idea so much
that i wasn't accountable to an audience
now that's a huge privilege it's a
really great opportunity but i didn't
really
know that until i started to
go into developing the marketing plan
and the release plan for our feature
because i was like wait a minute
what's my relationship with this
audience do i care about my audience or
not
and do i even have one um i don't
presume that anyone
looks me up or cares about me and maybe
that'll change someday
but that's not why i do what i do but i
care about them i was at
i was at a premiere last week
doing a q a and the first thing i did
before i said anything or answered any
questions
the person was very feverish they really
wanted to ask a lot of questions and it
was and it was cool they were awesome
but before i did that i thanked
everybody
i said uh i said you don't have cinema
without an audience you can have a film
without an audience
because you made a film and it's just
there
but if you try to show it in the theater
and no one goes it's not cinema because
no one saw it
and so when i said that out loud it was
sort of like a
it was like the finishing of an arc of
an idea where i was like wow people
paid money to see my film
and that doesn't make me feel good from
an egotistical point of view
i mean it doesn't make me feel bad but
it makes me feel like the idea
that i wanted to understand why they
would want to see it
felt complete and in that moment
very
[Music]
very personally in that moment all i
wanted to do was
make my next film and finish it
because i wanted more
audience members to see the next piece
of work
and so i think there's a relationship
between
marketing and branding and
understanding that you have to have an
audience for it to be
a high-level piece of work and and i
hope people
can figure out their own relationship
with making art
and marketing their art and
generally speaking it's a tough ask so i
would just say people should
open their minds
and you did a short film about is it an
art thief
so what happened with that was uh i
wrote
my friend and i wrote a feature about a
heist
an art heist that's real and
we wrote it and we shopped it to two
people and i hadn't
i hadn't directed a feature yet so it
was
they said basically you can do two
things with this script
you can sell it on spec and that was on
a table
you know it has a um it has
a ocean's 11 tone to it um but it's a
little bit darker than that
it's kind of like um
american animals sorry nah it's it's a
little bit like
there's a grooviness to um american
gangster
uh with denzel washington russell crowe
um which is a period film in the 70s but
um about frank lucas uh who sold heroin
in new york
um but there's a grooviness to that
movie where you're like oh there's like
a sense of humor to it
but it's also serious about what they're
talking about and
there's a grooviness to like ocean's
eleven and there's a great sense of
humor
but then it doesn't have that serious
component right it never gets really
serious ever
um and so the film we were working on
had a tone of that
um but anyway to make a long story long
um we wrote the script and they said hey
you can you can sell it on spec
or you could do something with it and i
had time between
commercials or between a music video and
a commercial
and i said hey let's let's just shoot
some scenes from it so it's sort of
billed as a short film and it's not
it's it's a short film has to have a
beginning middle and a short film
whether it's five minutes or
11 minutes has to have act one act two
x-ray it has to right
and this doesn't this has this kind of
like picks up
sort of in the beginning of act two and
then it ends
and it and and you meet the thief uh
under circumstances which are very very
odd where he has to prove a painting is
real or not and his life is in the
balance
and then um he is recruited after doing
that
to steal the real one because he proves
that the one they're looking at to fake
and uh um so we shot this
kind of like kind of like you take a
script and you're like hey we're gonna
shoot page seven through twelve
right so we did and um
uh after that experience um
i got another uh another gig came up for
me and then after i shot that i went to
new zealand and so we kind of put that
all on ice
and also we we polished that script the
guy who
we co-wrote it and um and he did a big
polish of the script
and it's probably like a 20 million
dollar film so it's on ice because it's
like hey man that opportunity is not
knocking at my door right now and i'm
not gonna undershoot it like i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna bring the scope of the
script down to like
three or four million dollars because it
needs to be what it is right so now you
have to have that discipline of
did we spend all this time on this
script and is it ever going to get made
or
was that just really exciting during
that period of our lives so it's been on
the shelf for like
six years yeah that's the danger of when
you put something on imdb
they're like oh my gosh this must have
been like an official official official
thing and you're like
no dude i just it was a great project
and we had a good time doing it and
it is a very very interesting story
we're passionate about
so when people do ask us about it which
is infrequent um you guys totally
did your uh r d here uh
when people do ask us about it it's
something where we're like
you know you want to drop kind of like a
easter egg or a breadcrumb and be like
yeah hey look for that in five years or
or whenever we get 20 million dollars to
shoot it so
anyway there are other priorities
between now and then sure so yeah just a
few meetings away
right yeah yeah but you used a lot of
the people or some of the people
uh in that art thief heist movie
to then co-write and then be an echo is
that right
um so the lead actor in
the art portrait of an art thief's name
is lathrop walker and he's the leading
actor in echo
um but he and i have been friends for 16
years
we went to acting school together he's
an extremely talented actor
we lived together when i lived in la so
it's sort of that ben affleck matt damon
thing
we we co-wrote some stuff we wrote stuff
individually
um and so
what happened with ekka was he and i
co-wrote the story
sort of a treatment that developed over
over some time
and i took the treatment and
needed to have a script
development session that was really my
voice as a writer director
but we both built that story and we've
we've written
several treatments together of films
that are coming up
um but my relationship right now
with the way i need to work is i need to
write the script
because the way i'm going to write it is
the way i'm going to shoot it right
and what i mean by that is to give you a
couple of
examples like if you read the
script to prisoners or if you read the
script to science of the lambs or
7 or blade runner 2049
you're reading the work of
screenwriter's interpretation of that
story and the visuals and the scope of
that story
but the no directors contributed to that
script so if you read that script you're
going to read it just like a script
now if you read anything that
christopher nolan writes or michael mann
or james cameron
you're reading a script from a writer
director and the tone
and the style of the writing is going to
be very different
because those writer directors are
writing it
because that's the way they're going to
see it and that's the way it's going to
be interpreted
and those documents without being cold
about it those documents are very very
different
uh i have a friend who writes for marvel
and he has read everything i've ever
written
and um he's like you're gonna shoot this
dude
you're totally gonna shoot this and i'm
like yeah of course i am and he's like
yeah because you write he's like you
write it
like there are no other ways for me to
interpret the visual language of this
film
and so my relationship with lathrop is
we have we have a co-writing
relationship in the story phase of
things that's highly organized and
highly developed
and we've tried to co-write scripts
together
we've tried once or twice and and the
the the way of working didn't work for
me personally
and had nothing to do with his creative
energy or his
uh genius as a storyteller he's very
brilliant very layered storyteller
it had to do with the voice of the
script it had to do with the way i
wanted
everything of the dialogue to sound or
the way i wanted to interpret the scene
description of
presenting to the reader the way i want
the film to be
and um so we did co-write the story to
echo
um and i've known for a long time that
i wanted to cast him as a leading man in
my first film
i trust him implicitly it's the same
vice versa we've worked together on
short films as you know we've worked
together on commercials we've worked
together on music videos
we worked together on a very very
intense action music video that was kind
of like
narc and traffic together and he was
a very interesting character he's
classically trained actor
so when we talk about character
development
we're talking like two actors are
talking to each other right it's
it's not top down like sometimes they'll
be on a set
and you'll watch a director be like i
think you should be nicer
just be nicer and and and actors like i
don't know what tell that means
you know so he and i have this
relationship that we have this
incredible shorthand
director to actor and we're best friends
so we it's just this brotherhood thing
and uh
um when people see echo they see what
michael
lathrop's character goes through in the
film and that's a tall ask if that guy
was a movie star
uh for for for a movie star or an a-list
actor to go through that with a
first-time director would be a super
tall ask
but that's not what i thought about when
i cast him when i
when i wrote michael in the script i
wrote it for him
he was going to do it um so the other
aspect of your question
was other people i worked with on
art thief helena grace donald
interestingly enough when um i went to
uh they have these um you know what they
are and
um you know these acting master classes
right right
so there's these showcases where actors
come from all over the world to
hollywood or
la and they work with a acting teacher
and there are some that are great and
then there are some that are like
gurus without
mentioning the ones i've gone to because
those are my opinions
i've gone to a few that are fantastic
and i've gone to a few that were not a
good use of time and i went to one that
was fantastic
and i watched uh
i went with a casting director who said
um and this is years ago this is before
we did art thief we were casting for
something else
and she said hey i want you to take a
look at some people and i said all right
and i watched probably 14 scenes and out
of those so it's 14 scenes times two
actors out of like 30 actors or whatever
she just blew me away and when she was
like 20 like 19 or 20
from london and
uh i said you know hey let's
let's talk to her and um i was right
about to
i do we just pulled those pages from art
thief we're like hey man we're gonna
give this a go
uh and there's a character who's a
who's the daughter of a powerful
billionaire art collector
and she collects black market art and
she doesn't really care
how it is acquired she's a character
that when we wrote
it she was like in her mid-30s and she
was
um we were always imagining like
cate blanchett we were always imagining
a powerhouse
who could just with one word or look
could just
hook you and uh
i told helena about the character i said
you know i'd like you to
read with lathrop lathrop plays the art
thief
and i said you know i really need you to
convey that level of
gravitas and power and she's threatening
him for most of the
film and that's a very tall ask
and she just killed it and i said okay
great
so she was in it and she was fantastic
her and lathrop had a lot of great
chemistry
and and then we worked on one other
small project together we tested for
something for one of the studios
and and then she went off and did a
couple movies
and i went to new zealand and then when
i came back from new zealand um
we were casting for echo and i called
her and i said hey i wrote this role
and i thought of you for it and you
don't need to audition
but here's the scoop you know and i told
her about it and
right away it was a very wise decision
and uh and again their their chemistry
and echo is
very very dense and it's
um it's fragile there's magnetism
between them that can only come from
really enjoying the scene work with
someone else you know you have people
who
don't give you any juice if it's not
their coverage right
and they are actors who are absolutely
present with each other and so
that comes across in echo big time but
only those
only those two actors yeah
when did you start writing the
screenplay for echo six months before we
started shooting
so what what happened was
we wrote the story to like i said i
wrote
several scripts when i was in new
zealand all of which were
uh beyond what our investment group had
put together
so they were kind of like films that
were outside the scope of what i could
execute
so i said okay great these will just
have to hold so then we collaborated on
a very interesting
uh um script and we wrote that
and it and then i took a a big pass at
that draft of that particular
film and i got to the end of it and i
said
it's the same issue it's too big for
what we can
shoot so i put that on the shelf and i
said
i really really really wanted to do that
but it's just not the right time which
takes a lot of discipline and you have
to kind of like
get over it pretty quick so then we sat
down and i said he had this idea so i
i sent him two page id i was like yeah i
have an idea bang bang bam bam bam
and he was like oh that's super
interesting and then he came back to me
and said well what if it's set here and
here and here so we went through a
couple of
versions of that treatment where at one
point the film was set in a hotel
that was very time oriented um sort of
like a ticking time bomb of a film and
then we expanded that
and we got the treatment to a place
where we both felt like we really
understood the characters
and then i said okay i want to write
this
and he's like for sure man so i
um wrote it in i think i did
four drafts of the script and
uh and then we were in pre-production
because we had a timeline on
our capital so
so um we didn't have a release date we
had
a certain amount of capital put together
and there was a time
timeline on that capital the other thing
that was super critical in his life and
this is personal but
you people can figure it out pretty
quickly is his wife was pregnant with
their first child so we had this capital
constraint
and then we had a life constraint and so
we had this
um you know in the can deadline
that we were working against and uh
so yeah six months and how did you get
access to the capital how are you you
could be are you in new zealand flying
back and forth to la
i think at that time yeah no no at that
time i had moved back
uh i had moved back full time and uh
by then when i moved back i had a
business model in my mind of what i
wanted to do
and i was super clear about well i had
had the business model
for years and along with writing
in new zealand i had done a lot of
research i had done a lot of research
with
studios there i've done a lot of
research with film distributors there
what works what doesn't work how does a
film make money how does it lose money
um and built a business plan there
while we were running this ad agency and
um
so i came back from new zealand and i
was like this is what we're doing
and um so then i put together an
investment group
out of seattle there's a couple people
in new york but it's mostly in seattle
so basically i sat down with people that
i knew who trusted me a lot
and i said this is what we're going to
do
and they said awesome
the biggest challenge the biggest hurdle
i had wasn't trust and it wasn't
execution
or they didn't think i was going to make
a product that didn't
live up to the standards of what they
saw on my commercial reel
they thought about time you know there's
a lot of time variables with film like
when's the script going to be ready
what if you get rained out of a location
what if someone gets hurt
etc from a producer's perspective
there's tons of variables which
in an investment world is called risk
management and
so we developed a very very calculated
risk management strategy
so all those folks felt like their
capital was protected
and uh and then we met those
we met those requirements and beyond as
far as budget goes and time goes
and i credit a lot of my um well i
credit all of my
commercial production experience with
staying on
target and um being relentless with
deadlines and so forth
and so yeah it was a very tight timeline
um and there were times when that was
that there were times when that felt
like
it was um
reckless a couple times meaning
our goal was to achieve something in
this amount of time
and and every once in a while there is
this there is this thundering hammer of
reality which was like you didn't know
this no matter how many ads you've shot
no matter
where you shot no matter what conditions
you've shot under
and that's when that's when you realize
this is
this is 32 days this is not two or three
this is a feature um
and and so that that period of time was
a reckoning what were some of the
recurring questions you were trying to
ask yourself while writing echo
i think the the recurring question i
wanted to ask
myself was why is this personal for the
main character
the genre that i wanted to work under
which is the
spy thriller genre
is very well tread very very worn
there are not a lot of trails to be
blazed there
so i wanted it to be a portrait i
started there i started okay this needs
to be
very intimate um about the main
character and
why he needs to know what he needs to
know and
so and it expanded from there
thematically to me
which was he needs to know where he came
from
not because he has amnesia or something
like jason bourne but he needs to know
where he came from because
he is going to be a father and his wife
is pregnant in the film
and she's very far along um but they're
balancing their life
with the fact that he's a crab fisherman
so he's gone for months at a time
and one of the reasons why i wrote him
as a crab fisherman was
um i know a lot of fishermen and
they will tell you that there are a lot
of um
you know interesting people on those
boats there there are nomads
there are outlaws there are people that
are fugitives
and there are captains of those boats
who make a decision about whether or not
they're going to pay someone in cash or
in check
and so forth generally speaking the
industry is very above board so i don't
want to
come across as someone who's disparaging
to the fishing industry which is
extraordinary
but there are there are people you meet
who you say man i really
wonder about his past and i was in a bar
and i was writing i was expanding this
character who was a former assassin
and i was talking to my friend who's a
former fisherman and we were at a
fishing
bar so to speak and i started to look
around and i started to see him
in these faces i started to see like
he's these
this guy's running from something and
that guy's running from something and
i wonder if that guy's done time like
hard time right and um
so i went back and looked at some of the
research methods that michael mann used
for his first film thief
and some of the research he did for
miami vice and for
l.a crime story and for heat which is my
favorite film of all time
uh and he really
talked to people who are criminals they
talk to people who are cops and talk to
people who are dealers and so forth
so i was like all right i'm really gonna
the questions i'm gonna ask myself are
why does he matter why would i believe
this why would he go from being a
professional
high level killer who's paid to do this
and works for a
clandestine organization to working on a
fishing boat
so i kept asking myself you know how can
we keep this grounded
you know how can we keep this story
believable um
what ended up happening was in the
script was
the film became a love story and i think
some audience members have really
responded well to that
you know i think they really think the
film is beautiful
i think some audience members expected
john wick 4
you know they expected uh a smash
action picture with stunt sequences
and it's not that and in the marketing
we tried to
make it more beautiful and in the
way we promised to deliver the film to
the audience
we tried to talk about its love story
and the complications of that
and so the questions i kept asking
myself when i was writing it was
um if this
man's going to be a father then he has
to know his beginning too
and and if someone
found him right if he wants to live in
obscurity
and if he wants to be a ghost and have a
quiet
life if someone found him who knew truth
what would he do what would he do to
protect that
and and that's where everything
started because the treatment later open
i had was the story of the film but
that's not the motivation
for a character that's like this happens
and this happens and this happens and
this happens and then it ends like this
right
and it was very interesting because when
i went to go write the script
the ending changed um when i went to go
write it the relationship between
who his father was changed uh and the
organization
went from being sort of a global
question mark empire or organization
like terrell corporation and blade
runner or wallace corporation and blade
runner 2049 we're like wow this is this
ubiquitous like
evil apple right and it changed
completely to like this very
private family-owned company
that's protecting its interests so
everything
became more grounded and i kept asking
myself how can i make this more of a
portrait of
of one man's life instead of making it
about like
corporate espionage which it does have
in it so
why did you need to tell this story
wow it's like asking me why i have to
breathe
um i knew from doing
years of ads i knew from writing
both in seattle and los angeles and new
zealand
that all of the energies of those
pursuits were pointing me towards
um making a feature
and crossing over so to speak like
crossing the line from ads to you know
doing from doing sprints to
a marathon and um
everything anybody tells you about
shooting a film uh
about its rigor and its
sheer impossibility is true
um from my experience it's true
and i remember
the drive of we started this now we have
to finish it
and the feeling that
we could you know we had all the right
people to make a complicated very very
layered story come to life
um and then um internally
i had to push myself as hard as i could
ever like it's like doing
200 commercials in a month right
and and keeping
a balance and a discipline for the work
and my visual aesthetic and
the cinematographer calls me
we are very close and he's and he says
he says you are the guardian of the
image and what that means is it's a very
high compliment but more importantly
than being a compliment what he means is
i'm
looking at everything for every shot for
everything and
i storyboard everything i call every
lens on every shot
um and so i think i had to kind of have
this um
um baptism by fire
um any of those awesome phrases
um but it but it was also climbing a
mountain i've used that metaphor a lot
to the point of
i'm sure if some people watch this who
know me they'll be like oh he's talking
about mountains again
but there are times i've read a lot of
books uh i've read a lot of
true story biographies about different
climbers
and there are times they talk about
moving in a group getting to base camp
moving to this other camp
moving to this other elevation
and then they talk about like summiting
or getting somewhere where they climb in
the dark
or they climb alone and that's why i had
to do it i had to
i had to finish it and i had to get to
the top
and there's still no sense of
satisfaction or
pride or any of that it's just
it's like that quiet feeling of you did
it
but it doesn't feel good like it doesn't
feel like
joyful you know it feels like
it feels like you're more obsessed than
ever
to do it again so six months
to finish the script for echo so you
started with
i know you said the ending changed at
some point yeah are you
outlining what are you doing to begin
this script um
i started with the first image of what i
wanted the audience
to see which also changed
and i started with the
pacing and um that's one thing that's
very
important that people know and the
marketing team
could have done a better job with this
and they they focused on other things
the pacing of it is reminds you of like
a european crime film it's not
an american like i said action picture
so i started with that which is like
what's the tone of this
when people are talking with each other
are they saying what they mean or are
they lying and most of the scenes
they're saying what they think they can
say
but there's a lot of other meaning so
for example i knew that a two-page
dialogue scene was going to clock to
like three and a half minutes on
film because i needed to give actors
room to work
and so i took the treatment
uh which was it was i would say it was
thorough in some places and
not thorough in other places i'll give
you an example of that the treatment
that we
do that we did and that we do has no
dialogue in it
and that's because the style of the
dialogue i write is very specific
and most of the time what it is is
what's not said
and that takes tremendous acting talent
to nail
and some audience members love that
sense of like i'm watching their look
and it's not telling me the thing but
then it's going to an hour later
and other audiences members don't like
that they want to be like
you know they want it to be very on the
nose
i'm not going to be able to deliver the
thing they want i'm always going to
deliver that other thing
so i remember starting to build
um there there are
uh there's a timeline structure to the
film
there's a there's a um there's him in
his life
and then there's what he's remembering
about his
um past and there are mirrors in the
whole film
so i remember building the mirrors in
the script first
and then being like okay this scene into
this into this and he's remembering this
how
and this is how we're showing his memory
and this is how we reveal that
um and i also was building a layered
script in that the audience
it's an invitation for the audience to
do work it's not
it's not a very simple film to follow
and that's by design
i mean kubrick and nolan
these are these are screenwriters not
talking about their directing
which is masterful i'm talking about
their screenwriting they're demanding
they say i'm going to show you i'm going
to tell you a story but you got to be in
it you got to be into this journey
one of the things we were joking around
about it the premiere was
no one can go to the bathroom if you go
to the bathroom
don't come back because you're gonna
miss something right
obviously if you're in a cinema you
can't control stopping a film so
when it's on vod people can stop it or
on blu-ray um
so yeah so so um i i started with
structuring everything
and structuring the way things were
going to be revealed
and then i went into
writing some scenes dialogue very
meticulously some of those scenes
they just
you know you're like a channel you're
like i know exactly what they say and i
know exactly why they say it
and then other scenes um
i'm i always err on the side of no
dialogue i always err on the side of i
don't think people need to talk to say
anything so the script was very short
at first the first pass was like 78
pages
and then the final script was like 94
and the movie's two hours so that means
i'm a visual director that it
shows a lot of information without
people talking
and um so yeah that's
that's how i began my process by
structure and then
dialogue and then um polishing the
dialogue
and then polishing the way i wanted the
script to be read
quentin tarantino says something great
i'm going to paraphrase it because i
don't know the exact quote
but he says a script should be enjoyable
for the reader
you know whether it's made into a film
or not they should read it and enjoy
reading it
and that's important for me i'm very i'm
very
um turned on by even seeing description
not being overly written but being
specific
and being character driven even and um
yeah so those are the things i start
with
and you knew you had this finance sort
of ticking clock
so where is lathrop putting in his is he
really just doing more the back story
on his character how is he getting
involved um
we had uh getting involved in the script
uh he didn't until there was a final
script
so basically i took when i said i'm
going to take it and i'm going to write
it
i'm going to write it and that's why it
says written by me right
and it's not an ego trip it's like it's
it's written and directed by me because
that's the way it's going to be
right however um
once there was a solid draft right which
is like draft number dose
you know um uh i
he read it and we sat down and we talked
about it you know i said hey do you have
any questions
you know let's talk about it you know
and he was just starting to
get into developing his character pretty
thoroughly
so he's not coming at it from a writing
perspective he's coming at it from an
acting perspective
and then what i told him i wanted to do
was hey i said hey as i audition
a person for this role or this role or
this role he
may or may not be in the audition right
uh
he will he'll definitely not be in the
audition he'll be in the callback maybe
or he'll be in like the screen test
chemistry read right and i said hey
so you know i'm watching these carefully
and i'm revising as i go because i'm
watching an actress's interpretation of
a line
and she's doing her art in that call
back and you can get ideas from that
she's not she's not improving she's not
ad-libbing but she might take a pause
that's not there
or she might go through the scene and
you might be like oh man i gotta cut a
third of this i don't need a third of
this
that's never usually my problem usually
what it is is
something's missing some maybe an extra
line here of clarification um
and uh um he had he had i would say he
had like a handful of notes
um that were helpful because he's like
what about this or what about that
or or he'd say i remember in one uh
screen chemistry read he he did
two or three lines in a row and he
switched them up every time
and he didn't switch them up because he
doesn't know his lines
because he's perfect in that capacity he
switched them up because he's like
let me try this and i was like yeah man
and they were better and so you go okay
cool that's great
um and then uh
the other thing that happened with the
script uh was
um after it was in the can
i knew when the film was shot i was like
i know i need to restructure this in the
cut
so my structuring of events
in the script
were the pacing wasn't right for what we
got
and that's a reality of
the relationship between what you think
is going to work on the page
and what you get on the day and what you
get in your assembly and your assembly
is the truth and um uh there's no
you know you can read something on a
page 100 times and be like this is going
to work totally it's totally going to
work
totally and then you shoot it and you go
something was weird about today or
something's weird about
the movie you're putting together in
your mind as you as you shoot i'm
building the movie right
in my head and i know i know it's going
to come before and after something i
know the
pacing of a moment and you're on set
that day and you're like man
something's not working and i don't know
what it is yet
and then you put an assembly together
and you go i know exactly what the
problem is and
you make two choices there you
restructure the cut
with the material you have and we had a
lot of great material
so 80 of the story restructuring
could happen in the cut and then you
figure out what's missing
because of time or because you didn't
know you wanted to
add those shots to the story and and i
knew we knew when we started day one
that we were going to do pickups and
reshoots we knew that before we even
started
not like a studio that might do two
months or what have you i don't know
you know or reshoot a whole like world
war z they shot like the last third of
the movie again
but i knew that we were going to do a
few days and as the assembly came
together
that that two or three days turned into
six days
and it really allowed me to and it was
it was a it was mostly um pickups
it was not re-shoes we only did the
stuff we re-shot was like
insert stuff that i wanted something
tighter of or um
or a flashback moment i wanted something
more significant of
so those are the reshoots but everything
else was shots that i knew i wanted
during production that i was like i'm
going to get those later on
and so yeah
what makes a great story i think what
makes a great story
for me i have two different
responses to this question because
i love film i love movies
and i love a lot of different kinds of
movies if you look at what my collection
is or if you ask me for like a top 10
list
it's quite curated around my
sensibilities and what i want to
re-watch and what i want to study
for future craft yeah
but if you looked at those you'd still
see a lot of different kinds of stories
and so first of all i'd say that
something about what the character
must accomplish turns you on
like you can see yourself in
him or her what they have to do is very
very very interesting to you
and generally speaking the kind of
stories i like
the stakes are incredibly high you know
we're talking about life and death
we're talking about someone figuring out
a big piece of information about their
life
if you look at the scripts that we have
in development and if you look at my
next couple of projects you see that
all of these from a stakes perspective
0-10
are a 9 right at least and that's
because
there's a contrast between your life
your life every day right that ticks
away and
however you spend your day and then when
you go and watch a piece of
entertainment
and i think that um the films that last
for me are ones where the stakes are
very very high
and where the protagonist doesn't know
something very important
and that doesn't need mean it needs to
have o henry ending
or an m night shyamalan twist or what
have you
there's this devotion to learning about
their journey and uh so a great story i
think
has those components i'm a bit of a
romantic
and um so i
look at the fact that the protagonist
is involved in some kind of love story
or love conflict
or is also dealing with you know they're
kind of dealing with a macro
conflict and they're dealing with micro
conflicts because that's super real
and where a story loses me
is if there are no micro conflicts if
it's just
i gotta go to the end of this place and
kill all these people and that's it
then it it it loses me you know
i'm very entertained by john wick i have
a tremendous amount of respect for those
filmmakers
a tremendous amount of respect for all
the training they do and their execution
the truth of it for me
as a writer director is
i enjoy all of the
ways they execute that concept of a
movie but i walk out of that film and i
stop thinking about it
you know i stop i get my car and i drive
away and i oh yeah there's a pearl jam
and i suddenly that's it i think the
most
interesting stories um that i'm trying
to write and
shoot and make into work and the most
interesting stories that are in the
collection of films i was mentioning
are stories that have layers that don't
serve you maybe everything you need the
first viewing
and so in addition to uh you know
high high stakes in their macro
objective in addition to the protagonist
dealing with the truth of a real
relationship
in the story i think the third thing for
me is that
um there has to be a sense of
intellectual structure to the story
it has to make me think about
the world they're in or make me think
about the inner workings of that
protagonist
or make me think about or
question my own relationship
because of the amount of truth in that
story you know sometimes you
you are in a marriage or relationship
and you watch a marriage
or relationship on screen and there's
this profound
truth in the script and in the acting
and the directing and it
makes you reflect on yourself and those
are the three things i
really look for in a great story
definitely
there's an article i read i have it
saved in a folder that i go to sometimes
when i need to
come out of the darkness like out of
editorial or out of like a writing
um period and i i go
back to it when i need to
sort of shake uh the reality tree
you know where you say hey what i'm
doing is really important or what i'm
doing is myopically
obsessive in this particular scene that
i'm writing or this particular moment
we're cutting and editorial
and the article is an interview with
david fincher
and the title is you better be
serious
because that's probably one of the big
turn-ons for me is i work with people
who are very
serious about this work and
so i've had a very interesting
relationship having not been on any
panels
uh i don't know if it's because people
don't like me but i think it might also
be because
there's like a um there's like a
devotion
to the technical practicality of
execution that's what i want to talk
about i want to talk about
doing the thing i don't want to talk
about the thing you know
and so maybe someday people would be
interested in what i have to say
we'll see when you pull up that article
yeah what does it do for you i'm sure it
varies from time to time
like how does it make me feel um
it's like a it's like a mentor i don't
have you know it's like a person where
you say hey man am i on the right track
here
you know am i like blinded am i missing
out on life because i'm taking
this work so seriously and it's a
reminder from a craftsman who i have
the highest regard for um
that i should just keep going
and that sometimes it's really lonely
and
sometimes um it's very isolating
um and then sometimes there are people
who have no
connection to the industry and you
engage with them whether they're your
friends or your family
and they don't understand why you care
so much about what you're doing
and then two years later they see your
film and they
maybe they understand a little but they
still don't so
the article reminds me that i'm on the
i'm on the war path
and just keep going and being
a little bit removed from the
entertainment industry being in
washington state i know there's a lot of
artists up there yeah there's music or
fine art whatever
i live there most of the time but i'm
here all the time but you're here all
the time okay so
we're sort of like dual residence sort
of uh it's probably like
at this stage it's probably like 75 25.
80 20 something like that you know so
so then you go to another you're you're
at least being exposed to both areas and
you're seeing a different mindset
yeah and so you're not probably hearing
about
yeah so we're working on this screenplay
it's the local market
that you're frequenting or yeah i had
this call back or whatever
right so does that help you does that
help you stay
more in quote the real world or do you
not feel as motivated because you're not
hearing about
the industry all around you at all times
that's a great question um
for my personality which is driven
by myself like i don't need someone to
kick my ass every day
i think that having the dissonance
having the distance
also away from hollywood is
a real positive thing for the way i work
um i think that there's a way to get
distracted in the labyrinth
of the way the industry
wants to give people value um
and the way they want to
create um
energy and hope which when
i was living here full-time i found the
energy
and hope that was being created was a
very uh double-edged sword i felt like
the energy and hope that was being
created for
for me when i lived here was optimism
it was fueling my tank it made me want
to meet
great actors and great producers it made
me want to try to move my
career forward the flip side of the coin
is
you're exposed to the fact that every
door is locked
to you whether you're a director or an
actor or a producer
and that there are only a certain number
of ways
to get a key um and
so going to new zealand
offered me a reprieve from that search i
didn't have to think about like how was
i going to get a key to talk to
someone at village road show or how was
i going to get a key to go down and talk
to the people at weta
you just go i mean you call and you talk
to them and
decide if they want to meet you etc
and i really benefit from
creating my work elsewhere and
not being part of the
um machine
with its highs and lows with the way
that it decides it's going to tell me
that my work's valuable
um however
i think the industry is tremendously
interesting
i i think the entertainment industry is
the one of the most unique business
models in the whole world
and there's discipline about
understanding it and respecting it
that i think it's very easy to it's very
easy to get angry
about not being able to get a key to the
door and you can't get in
and then being really pissed off about
that and then saying you know
hollywood and having that
attitude and i don't have that attitude
at all i really i respect it when i
drive down
highland and i see the dolby theaters
advertising i'm like i know why that's
there
and i know what it's doing
to uh add value and build the profile of
that studio's release i get all that
right
but so far i have had the opportunity to
work with people here
in sort of a satellite capacity where i
come to town i work with them where i
come to town and we talk about what
we're going to do
and then i leave and i go home
and that's been
the best process for me and
it's been super rewarding it's also
allowed
me to look at the machine
of hollywood with a different focal
length
you know and i've actually learned to
have a much better sense of humor about
it
you know and i think when i lived here i
didn't when i lived here i was
i was so focused on making my way
towards one of those doors
that i didn't step back and try to just
look at it all and
think about how it all works it's an
incredible watch
it's an incredible mechanism with so
many variables um
and there are
a lot of very very smart people here and
there are a lot of people here who are
full of a lot of darkness
and um
it will always be interesting whenever
i'm flying in whenever i'm
coming into town and i get off of
kuanga by a hollywood bowl i'm whenever
i drive into hollywood i'm always like
uh
yeah yeah start looking behind the veil
do you mind me asking why you left l.a i
know you were
flying to new zealand which was doing
this advertising marketing
and then at what point did you leave la
for good or not for good right you're
open to coming back yeah i think i think
it was never like i'm never going back
there again
i think my relationship with
i mean essentially my relationship with
how much time i had to spend here
changed and it's never um
it's never gone back to being full-time
so my opportunities in new zealand my
opportunities were shooting a lot around
the world
regarding that new zealand australia
london etc
they were far more interesting than
me being here hitting the pavement and
maybe not getting a key to that door
it was like about building my craft and
having time to write
in a place that is one of the most
beautiful
countries in the whole world and it was
a refueling of the soul
and then when i came back i knew that i
wanted to shoot a film right away and
i wasn't going to shoot it here for
infrastructure reasons for cost reasons
for relationship reasons i had more
relationships in the pacific northwest
but there are a lot of people on the
talent side
and the management side and the legal
side
and the distribution side of course that
i work with here so
i come back regularly and
a goal of mine outside of the immediate
path
is to work with a studio you know
definitely i
would like to have the right group of
producers at
the studio i would like to have the
right amount of support
and i'm very interested in
that part of the experience where i can
bring what i do in my process
and my drive and my thoroughness
to a studio project because the way they
operate
their protocols their timelines
are so fascinating and i
you know i finished the film in los
angeles at e-film
so i was working side by side with other
directors who were on studio movies
and we were all in the same kayak you
know my studio was not or my film was a
non-studio picture
theirs were so for example when we were
doing rdi
it was the cinematographer and i alone
in a room next door they were doing
a very large budget picture and there
was 20 people in the room
so that's the big difference is their
protocols and their operations
involve more support they also involve
more people whose opinions matter to
that product and i think working in the
parameters of that would be
very very interesting when the time's
right and
i also kind of look at it like if
anyone's interested
in in my work and in our work that we're
doing
they're going to want to have that trust
in my filmmaking style
and in my execution to be able to trust
me with
a real significant budget so the goal
you know the end-all be-all goal is not
necessarily to work
at or for a studio but i'm truly
interested in wanting to do that
as part of the journey because their
parameters for success and the way they
support you
is very different than when you're an
independent
did you shop around the script for echo
to production companies
no and so that was never a plan you had
this business model that you developed
for a few years
yep and you knew certain people that
would maybe say yes to it
maybe say yesterday how in terms of
being an investor
there were group people different our
investment group is not a one-off thing
you know our investment group is a slate
of movies
and um so the way i structured the
model was like a startup like a tech
startup
where you say we're going to make this
product we're going to go to market here
here are revenue opportunities and
[Music]
none of the investors that i have in our
our
team uh have ever invested in film
before
and they don't have some strong opinion
coming out of
a sundance market or a a con market
they've invested in technology companies
and they've invested in
equity firms and et cetera and so
the model turned them on because it was
a company that builds its own asset and
owns the asset
and sells the asset globally and it
was just coincidental that the asset is
a film so that's
part of the pitch is i don't really talk
about
making movies they're all passionate
about it they're all interested in it
they loved echo every one of the
investors responded very well to
the final film which is super critical
but no one was ever no one read the
script
no one asked to read it and if they had
asked it i asked i wouldn't have given
it to him
because that diverts the path
of what we're doing you know the path is
so singular
and there uh morgan freeman once said
don't
accept criticism from someone whose
feedback you wouldn't ask for
and so it's like i wouldn't ask you know
john doe investor for feedback on a
script because
you know what would be the point of that
and that's no disrespect super super
smart
smart brilliant people in this team
so you keep it as efficient as you can
and then you pay really close attention
to how the process went
pay really close attention to
every aspect of selling the film and um
and then we stay on the path so yeah you
had a lawyer draft up all these
documents and agreements and
for the company for for also for these
investors
yeah yeah so i have an entertainment
attorney in los angeles
and i have a securities attorney in
seattle
so the securities attorney knows nothing
about films what they know about is
building an investor's package
for whether you're doing a startup or a
seed round
or a series a and
you just have to know what you're doing
when you talk to people about investing
in a film
probably one of the most painful things
i've experienced
has been you know i've been to sundance
i've been to tiff i've been to
um a couple of other film festivals that
are sort of big
sif and yeah yeah i had a couple of
shorts and stuff when i was younger
but stiff isn't is in a marketplace
right and nobody buys a movie because it
went to sif
they buy a movie because it goes to one
of the selling festivals but um
but i remember having experience where i
was watching a film and i was near
a producer and their primary investor
and the film was not good and
um wasn't executed well and you could
tell from their conversation
that they didn't have a marketing plan
they had no sales plan they had no
release plan
they were at sundance on
a lot of luck maybe they knew some
people
sundance gives great films opportunities
and they try
certain films out and that's awesome
that's what they do
but i remember that experience vividly
that this investor had put a lot of cash
into a film that
didn't meet their standard of any film
and
there's no way they're getting any of
that back and so
and that was that was in 2007 or 2008 or
something
and um i remember that like
seared in my mind that if i do this
you know independently that i have to
come
to the table with a plan that brings
confidence and
um takes this stuff real
seriously
a lot david fincher so yeah are your
parents entrepreneurs did you watch them
build companies or my parents are super
super hard working
uh i watched their work ethic i watched
um
their uh they're both in education
my dad was the superintendent of public
school districts
uh with a phd my mom has a master's in
child psychology and
um uh taught um
special ed preschool kindergarten first
grade
these are wonderful wonderful people who
make the world a better place
and they're very supportive of this
i think there's a reality of
it's out of their wheelhouse
you know it's outside their wheelhouse
of wanting to start an equity company
it's outside their wheelhouse of um
wanting to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars on an
illusion
of entertainment that you'll sell to
people i think that there's something
really
practical and beautiful about every day
you go into
a classroom and you lift a mind up
or you take care of someone that needs
that and
um but they always supported my
madness and um but there's not
there's not a connective there's not a
parallel between their lives and their
careers and
anything i'm doing sometimes i think
that's exciting for them
uh other times i think it's curious
other times i think that it's um
there's like a sense of
there's a sense of they and they're very
deep
beautiful philosophical people and when
we were young
as kids um they said to us even when we
were very young
they said you know do something that
feeds your soul
right they didn't say go to law school
yeah they didn't say that
and um so as this has been evolving
they've seen
they've seen a path that has had swaths
of distance between success
and trying things out and travel and
i've always been on the move and so i
think it's
interesting for them to watch this come
to life
and uh and they both reacted very very
well to echo and i think that they were
kind of
there's a sense of not knowing
like is this real is what he's doing
really real you know
they've seen my commercial work and
stuff so no that's real but you know an
endeavor that takes years in the making
um
they there was a sense of like waiting
uh of is this gonna be any good
and so i think there was um
without them knowing through and through
everything about the industry
i think they were very excited that it
it was finished at the level it was
finished at and that it's
the beginning you know they know i'm
working on another film already and
so they're excited to i remember my mom
just saying
you know after she saw the film she had
a lot of questions about the film she
wanted to see it again right away which
is the perfect response
enjoying it and wanting to see it again
that's the best reaction to echo people
can have
but she also had a lot of questions
about what i was doing next
she's like this film is very complicated
and very interesting and very beautiful
so
what are you gonna do next what could
you possibly want to do next you know
and that was a wonderful reaction you
know um
and i'm super fortunate to
i've got a great family and they have
supported this
um all through my decisions to do this
kind of work
without understanding it
from an insider's perspective you know
they're looking at it from the outside
and they're still
supporting it which is really
it's a privilege to have that kind of
support yeah
so with your co-collaborator on echo
lathrop
walker did he train for the assassin
sort of scenes like oh yeah um oh yeah
um so we did two types of training
for lathrop to become michael
he's a very uh fit and very skilled
actor
and he's very physically oriented actor
he's done tons of
physical training as far as embodying a
character and developing them physically
so i knew that he was going to make him
specific
which is a tall order in this particular
script
but two things that he's not is he's not
an assassin
and he's also not someone who can
hurt someone else with their bare hands
so we divided up his training
into weapons training and into stunt
work
and the way the weapons training worked
was we sent them to itts which is in
simi valley
which is an internet international
tactical training group
they train special operatives they train
swat they train hrt
they train actors and
i did a lot of research around who would
teach him as quickly as possible
but who would be very serious and
very accountable for his learning now
he's super serious as an actor and he's
very committed to it
however if we have a short period of
time you need to have a teacher
or a coach who's gonna hammer you so
that you become
good quickly and they did that you know
he did several sessions they're
going from learning how to handle a
handgun all the way up to learning how
to handle an assault rifle
and he went from a guy who um you know
you
just would never see him with a gun at
home he would never have a gun
he went from that to being absolutely
lethal
with every weapon he was touching
there are videos we're training videos
we have on youtube that we show
him doing the gun training uh both
handguns and
um long rifles and then the second group
of uh stunt work we did
uh i hired a guy named adam noble who is
a fight corps
coordinator he does stunts for film
television
theater he's really well-rounded
journeyman but he's also
expert at physical movement for actors
he's trained intensely with the suzuki
method he's
trained intensely with stunt
choreography associations and fight
coordinators and
he's very very good at teaching an actor
along with being a great stunt man
himself so
what we did with adam adam is based in
houston so
what we did was i wrote the fight in the
movie the way i wanted to see it and i
sent him the pages and he read it
and then we talked about the beats of of
the fight sequences right there's three
or four of those
in the film and so what adam would do is
he would take a group of students at the
university of houston
in one of his movement classes and how
great is that for
a young actor to be like oh hey i'm
going to use you as a
you know a hit man or as a heavy in a
sequence
so we can frame and sketch the fight
and so adam would send me videos of that
and i would describe my shots or i'd
send him some storyboards so he knew
i said i only want coverage of the fight
from these perspectives because that's
how the audience will see the fight
and so he would send me these these
sketches and they were
it was two things that were great about
them one they were
very clear about the movement like the
beats you know this happens and this
happens this happens you know
nothing highly developed meaning nothing
moving at full speed really
because i didn't need to see that and
the second thing about them was
his students were great if i had notes
i'd be like hey man try this and try
that
and he would adapt it right away and
they were up for anything
but then we a couple days before we
ended up shooting those sequences
so lathrop had learned the fight from
videos
lathrop trained all day every day for a
week
with a group of professional stuntmen
with
under adam's guidance and
after a few days they brought me in and
they showed me the fight and they had
that that main fight sequence is very
quick and it happens on a dock
in a marina in a fisherman's terminal so
there's a lot of
spatial constraints it's very dangerous
um it's gonna be at night it's gonna be
wet
etc and um so
adam had put together a great fight i
wanted to be more brutal
i wanted uh it to better represent how
the character would
react to being surrounded
and most importantly what's most
critical about that fight in the film is
it's really from his wife's perspective
it's the first moment it's in the
trailer
it's the first moment his wife watches
him
and what he can do she doesn't know he
can do this
he goes he goes on a fishing boat to get
his paycheck
he sees some stuff on the fishing boat
which is just
scary and thrilling meaning someone is
going to come and kill him
and he comes off the fishing boat and as
she looks at him
and he looks at her he's surrounded by a
group of masked
men who are very well trained and
they're all professional stuntmen
and a couple of them are mma fighters
like these are really good fighters
and it was extraordinary
to see it go from video sketches
with students of atoms into this dynamic
fight i shot the whole thing with a
technocrat so it has a sense of fluidity
to it
and it's really a privilege to work with
uh adam and his team but it's also
proves to work with lathrop because
he takes every movement very very
seriously uh he takes every part of the
process
very seriously you see him like in the
training videos on youtube you see him
like you know pack guys on the back and
help him up and
he's a really great person
and that's what you want and an actor
who has to be violent towards another
person is you want them to actually have
the heart of someone who doesn't want to
do this
and then when they do have to do it it's
much more authentic
and he brought that fight to life
and uh the way it's shot is i'm very
proud of the way it shot because of
how much it uh brings the audience into
his wife's perspective
of i had no idea he was capable of this
and uh that moment affects sort of a
ripple
just that pebble in the water that
moment is
it ripples the rest of the film
regarding what his
what he's capable of how much time did
you have for pre-production so six
months writing scripts
right um well i was writing and location
scouting at the same time
and that's a producer mindset which is
don't write but you can't shoot
and so i was for example i was like
i want this sequence to happen on a
fishing boat
so i went down to um
the fisherman's terminal in ballard in
seattle
and i started walking the docks and
looking for a boat like what's the boat
that i want
for this movie um and then i started
looking at the dock and i was like maybe
the fight happens here yeah the fight
happens here
boom and then that's in the script and
then
um other things there's there's a
sequence with a private jet
and i was like okay how are we going to
get how we can pull that off
and so pre-production became quite
integrated in the scripts cr uh
the scripts right script writing out of
necessity
and out of i don't know i guess
learning that as a commercial director
you're like okay i got this script what
can we do how can we make it
how can we build that reality right now
and
um so pre-production began in earnest i
would say pre-production began in
earnest
around the middle of january because
that's when we did a camera test
and you start testing optics and you
start looking at what lenses are
friendly for the actor
you start looking at what lenses you're
going to be framing
your language with right there's a
vocabulary you're going to create
that was the middle of january and then
we started shooting on april 1st
what did you shoot on we shot on an ari
alexa
and it's a great camera
love it love it and were the lenses
part of the package did you get other
lenses from somewhere else uh we
well we have a great relationship with
kerner camera in seattle
and i've worked with them on commercials
before i moved to los angeles
so we had great rapport so as a producer
when i was going to be shooting up there
i knew we were going to rent from them
and um
so we sat down with them and we told
them what our budget was which was
more than they thought it was going to
be because they're used to supporting
independent film
they're used to people coming in and say
first of all used to people coming in
and asking for for free which is
ridiculous
and then they're used to people
negotiating rates or asking for a
certain weekly rate which is
on the verge of insulting so when we
came in we were super serious and we
said this is our budget and this is what
we're going to do and that's how long
we're going to do it for
so they were on board right away uh and
then i did my test
and um i tested
um kawas i knew i was gonna shoot
anamorphic
because i the film demands anamorphic
um and so i tested cowas
which are um older lenses uh they're
very um
mixed bag as far as the quality goes of
one set to another
so for example you might have a set of
kawa
anamorphix where the 75 in the set
is your hero and the optics of a couple
of the other like the 40 or the 100 or
for example
they won't perform as well whether it's
for the first ac
or whether it's for aberrations or uh
whether the flare is not working for you
if that's what you're into
and i tested those primarily because i
was fascinated by
how violent some of the moments are in
the film and if i wanted to
incorporate optics that would lift that
up and sort of add
supercharge it so however that was kind
of an outlier because
i knew that i was going to shoot cook
anamorphics
as my primary set um
since i started writing this movie so
yeah
and then how are you lighting it well we
have
a great relationship with pacific grip
and lighting in seattle they have
um a grip and electric house in portland
they have a gripen electric house in
seattle
and so pacific grip and lighting we call
them pgl um
they're run by it's run by a guy named
ray hammond and he
is someone i've known for my entire
career
so that first boxing movie that i shot
on 16
with those actors that all worked for
sandwiches um
the kino that we used i think we could
only afford to rent three lights
and we rented them from him and so he
and i have known each other my whole
career
and when i came back and said i'm ready
to do a film
and i'm the producer as well and this is
what everything looks like
he gave us a
a deal that's in the realm of generosity
that's very hard to
express because he believes in
me and he believes in what we're doing
and
um we're very gracious and we
appreciate everything that he does i
think
kind of like crooner maybe kind of like
other vendors have experienced
you know sometimes filmmakers aren't
full of gratitude sometimes they're
artists to the point of
ingratitude or they just forget to
acknowledge people
um we're not like that and so rey
was extraordinary in giving
our production the tools that i have
gotten used to using in commercial work
so you get used to using certain kinds
of lights you get used to using 18ks and
you get used to using sky panels etc
where
you're using some of the best
instruments that are made
and so
we had an incredible grip and electric
package the whole movie
and he didn't know
my cinematographer but i you know talked
about him and
he knows rey knows how particular and
specific i
am so he recommended a gaffer for us
that was local
out of seattle who's done tons of movies
and
is a very awesome guy
who takes no from anyone and
so he said i think you two are going to
get along
but if you don't then don't work with
them because it won't work
and he and i met for a coffee and like
in five minutes he was like oh you're
not around and i was like no
and his name is kevin cook he was our
gaffer and
kevin brought on a key grip named mark
bewing
and those two were those two created an
opportunity to create
those two created an opportunity for
duncan and i
to hold the bar as high as possible
right so duncan cole is my
cinematographer he and i
are brothers he and i have the
we work in the spirit of spielberg and
kaminsky we work in the spirit of
nolan and wally fister when that was his
dp
or deakins and the coen brothers he
is uh the cinematographer that i've been
looking for
for my career i've worked with a number
of cinematographers and
he and i just get each other and the
reason why we get each other we're both
photographers first
we're both looking at pictures
both creating pictures the second reason
is we don't
reference other films when we're doing
our process
creatively like when i bring my
visual reference materials to him and i
say this is what i want the sequence to
look like and the color palette's going
to shift over this arc and all that
their photographs or their paintings
they're not
stills from movies very rarely i will
say that i won't say never i'll say it
rarely
because we're not trying to emulate
another movie we're trying to
tell this story so he and i understand
lighting together very very specifically
and he knows that i'm a compositional
and a aesthetically driven director
visually
so we don't ever talk about composition
ever because i'm like this is what it's
gonna look like and he goes right on man
and and it's the same thing i've been on
sets before where
directors don't call the lens they don't
even know the focal length
they just say i wanted to do this and
that and then the dp calls a 40 or a 50
mil or whatever
and that's the opposite i call
everything and um
there were a handful of times maybe two
two or three where you said hey can we
look at it on this and i'm like yeah
sure man we can look at it on that but
we're not going to shoot it on that
and he's like all right cool and it
became a joke uh because sometimes he'd
want to look at it on a 50 and i'm like
we're shooting on 40.
he's like yes just look at it though and
i'm like all right cool and we'd look at
it and he's like what do you think
and i'm like well we just wasted five
minutes because we're gonna shoot it on
this
and it's not like a dictatorial thing
it's not like tyranny it's like
i know exactly what i want every shot to
look like and why
and so so in our relationship we're
beyond that
we're beyond that he is an incredible
lighting cinematographer so when we look
at
how we want the lighting language of the
film to be
um he communicates that directly with
kevin and mark
the gaffer and the key in accomplishing
that
and so from my work with duncan in the
past before we
did features together we had that
rapport where i'm like it looks like
this and here's why we come around here
and it's dark and super
silhouetted there and you know why he's
like okay and is that
it's like that and then he goes and
we i mean this very very very meticulous
process
right and then he goes this way and
works with
the gaffer and the key and i go this way
and work with the actors and we're both
super efficient
and he knows that
he called me once he said you are the
guardian of the image
and he didn't mean you're a control
freak he meant
you know exactly what you want so i
don't worry about that
right he wants it to look like the way
we want it to look so he's worried about
how it's going to be lit to work that
way
and from a technical perspective he and
i have a
very very dynamic vocabulary together
about all the tools
um not just optics or camera tools but
lighting instruments and things like
that and lighting quality and um
and color we talk a lot about color um
and that's because that's because
my goal as a director is i'm gonna bake
the look into the negative
i'm not going to shoot it flat and then
go into the di
with a color grade and make
the color grade make the frame work
right so there's a
latitude we've both talked about how if
we're working on a studio movie
more than likely we would have to shoot
our films flatter
right because the studio would want to
be able to have
more control in the color grade in the
di
and we don't abide by that at all and a
good example of that
is that we for some sequences we use
split diopters
so diopters especially on anamorphic
frames diopters
can be uh they can be spherical they can
be diagonal they can be pieces of glass
what the diopter does it changes the
magnification of the image
so that it appears blurry now you can
accomplish that in the di
you can make a power window you can add
a blur
or a gaussian blur you can make it look
milky
right like a flashback or like something
romantic
you can do that in post we didn't we put
it
on the map box and shot it that way
that's a commitment to the image you go
that's what we're doing
we're going to bake it in and if we
didn't know each other as well as we do
with that mutual trust we would
make more limited decisions we would
make less committed decisions
um but uh
everybody on that team on this first
feature kevin mark
their teams on the grip and on the gaff
side um
and the camera side uh we all became a
family they're all coming back
for the next film and uh
it was interesting for some of them who
had done
i won't say who it was but it was
interesting for some of them who had
worked on a lot of independent films
and working with us was different and
um we were very fortunate to have their
talent because
they had probably worked on some
projects they weren't really stoked
about
you know they had worked on some
projects that were just jobs and then
they um came on board echo and we built
this creative team
that was like everybody in like two days
everybody was like we all care about
how this is gonna be lit we care about
how fast the lens gets on that camera so
i can frame up that shot
we care about the sensitivity to a dolly
move you know the vocabulary
movement in a dolly on a track or
whatever and it was
um i'm super grateful for their
commitment they all invested and
i think it was a testament to the
professionalism you know they saw this
ripe opportunity to be like hey man i'm
gonna give a
and they all blew us away with how much
they cared about the film
and um so that was
you know that was awesome
just how someone took a chance on you
when your mom drove you to the
photographer's
building right right yeah to wait for
three hours right right
and but but for some reason he saw
something in you
for for those obviously it was just
planning to be it was a short meeting
but it ended up being three hours what
do you see in people that even though
some may have a great resume but you
didn't just tell the work ethic isn't
there
or vice versa maybe they don't you know
i remember one time i interviewed for a
job and i got it over somebody else and
i asked the
person years later why did you choose me
and she said
the other people they weren't hungry
enough
yeah that's that's a um i mean that's a
truthful response from her i'm sure
um so the question is what do i look for
in people i hire or
the question is what do i look for when
i want to work with someone again
because those are sort of different okay
well
then if you want to work with them again
does that boil down to work ethic or
also chemistry
that's that's a great question um
i think that um
the people that blow me away
when they're hired uh and
[Music]
um that i can feel a
sense of energy and commitment from
right away the thing
that stands out about what they're doing
is this
thing we're making this film we're
making right it
is forever for me right
so it's forever in the
two or three years of work leading up to
making it
it's forever in that it has my
artistic dna on everything and it's
forever and that it has my name on it
forever um but it's
the job they're doing maybe they
maybe they've only done this kind of
work for two years or three years or
whatever
i've been doing it for 14. so the
power of what i'm trying to accomplish
is very high
like it's very significant to power and
the work standard is very high and the
expectations are very high i've been
told that repeatedly by people who like
me and people who don't
which is your expectations are so high
so what i look for
is people who want to meet those or try
to exceed them
and people who care about the forever
thing you know
i'm not asking them to pretend to be me
that's
egotistical and ridiculous i'm asking
them to care
about as many of the moments that
they're working on this is possible
and it's a tall order but i set the tone
for that
and many many people uh get switched
onto that
because they go oh this is this is his
film so we're gonna
poof you know and that doesn't mean that
two months later they're not gonna be
working on something else and
be texting while they're doing something
else right
so i look for that um focus
like this sense of focus this matters
and
that they become a slightly myopic in
their
execution of what they're doing they
become obsessed with getting something
right
as well because that's um apple doesn't
fall far from the tree kind of thing
so i look for sort of
a natural obsession of wanting to
meet a really high standard of work and
it has to be consistent
there was a couple people on the set of
this picture
who got super tired and whose focus
blurred uh because of the stamina
of being focused like that every day all
day long is very very hard
and it's a turn off for me when it
happens i'm not
inhuman people are human i get it
but when i see other people
sustain their focus out of a devotion
to this project it really turns me on
and it makes me
work with them again and it makes me
want to give them more responsibility
depending on which
department they're in and um
yeah i think that's what i look for it's
like sense of
okay for this many weeks
this is what i'm doing absolute absolute
focus and commitment
knowing that it does end for them right
it doesn't end for me
for quite some time but it does end for
them and there's a bunch of people on
our team
who have been doing this for so long
that that turn
that switch for them of working on a
project like this for
six to twelve weeks depending on which
department they're in
is an easy choice because they say this
matters
you know and um and i'm very lucky to
have
so many of the people whose focus is
super high
want to come back in a heartbeat very
lucky
how terrifying was it to use the
equipment that you used on echo
in terms of just the cost of the lenses
oh yeah the the re-alexa package yeah
uh not terrifying at all uh i had used
everything before
um i had done a
i'd done a real significant camera test
in the months before
we shot principal photography
a few months before that i had done a
big project in new zealand where we shot
uh cook anamorphics and cook s4s
and before that i had shot an audi
commercial
um and we shot cocanomorphics they're
extremely expensive lenses
um all the tools we use were top of the
line you know we shot
alexa mini and cook anamorphics
and we used a technocrane we use an 18
a 25 and a 50. those are very
very expensive part of the
privilege and benefit of doing
commercial work is it can afford you
some great toys
and it can afford you the comfort of
using
um you know a metaphor would be like
the best the best chef's knife possible
and i had an opportunity to use
all of the best equipment far in advance
of the film
and um so i never thought about it
at all what advice do you have for a
filmmaker that
is now sort of graduating to this new
level
and they're terrified maybe they don't
want to let people know they don't
totally know what they're doing but
they're terrified of the experience or
terrified of the gear or
the gear oh of the gear uh be well
insured
first of all like i hear horror
stories uh from specifically camera
houses
both in seattle and panavision i know
people at panavin um
and camera houses in new zealand and
australia
i hear horror stories about you know
a film student or an indie filmmaker
coming in and begging and begging and
begging to shoot with a lens
or a couple lenses or whatnot and
they somehow let them out or they
somehow
work out a deal where they're very
underinsured and suddenly
you're doing two things wrong suddenly
you're cutting a professional corner
which you shouldn't cut because if
you're going to be
very real at doing this there are things
you have to do right
and one of them is to be very well
insured and if you
can't afford it you either need cheaper
gear that can fall under that policy you
do
have or you need to wait until you can
afford the right policy
because you're doing two things one
you're putting yourself at risk
you're putting a relationship at risk
with the camera house where
they're trusting you and you're
accepting that trust
and you actually don't have the ability
to fulfill that liability if something
goes wrong
and the second thing you're doing is
you're yourself
and your focus because if you need to
direct a movie or
lens a shot and you're worried about
putting it on
the camera you're wasting everyone's
time including your own
um i think there is
um there's an escalation that happened
for me technically you know i shot with
um i think we shot with a
rolly or a or a bolex
on my first film and then the second
short i did we shot on um
on ra16s and then the next
film we shot on the 435 extreme
and then the next project was
um a
alexa classic etc
and so it kind of goes back to like
originally
feeling like i don't deserve
the right to shoot something yet right
from my photography
apprentice days where i had to earn the
right shoot
a shot of film i had to earn the right
to shoot a shot of film
with a hasselblad i had to earn the
right to shoot
a piece of 4x5 film
and which is extremely difficult to work
with um
i think there's an excitement around the
tools and the toys and stuff
and that's super super natural i mean
it's very natural not supernatural it's
very natural
and that's okay but if you
if you can't handle it then you
shouldn't use it because
your focus needs to be about making the
project a success
not about um what lens is on your camera
because nobody cares you know very few
people
uh very few people outside of the film
industry know the difference between
anamorphic and spherical
they don't they don't they can't tell
you the difference
so they certainly couldn't tell you the
difference between a cook anamorphic and
a co-anamorphic
so you have to decide the right tool for
the job
and when someone's researching
production insurance policies
is there like a website you don't have
to tell me like a specific carrier
but where would they go to find various
carriers i think the the best way to do
it is you can do it outside in or inside
out so outside in would be you go online
and you look up film production
insurance and you make a list of
companies
and you reach out to them and you do
research and you do hard work and you
ask them lots of questions you be real
honest say i got 25 grand
so i want to shoot short with 25 grand
or
some people who are insane i'd say i
want to shoot a feature for 25 grand
and they'll say what are you renting
first thing they'll say what are we
covering
and you be honest with them that's again
you don't cut corners with insurance you
just be honest with them
you say i'm gonna shoot an iphone or you
say i'm to shoot it with a panavision
or whatever then that's
outside in you do all the research
yourself and then you catalog
their pricing their relationships right
probably a more strategic approach
is you get some face time
with an account executive at like
panavision hollywood
or panavision woodlawn or auto
or um you know any of the camera houses
in town and you say
i am producing my first project which
they have all heard a million times
ask for their time be real limited hey
can i borrow five minutes of your time
just have a couple quick questions
they'll probably be cool with it and
then you say
i'd really like to know where the best
producers get production insurance
who are independents because studios are
insured differently
so those people will say oh go to this
place this place or this place right
they get the policies from all the same
places
so for example in seattle where we shot
echo
there's really only two places to get
film production insurance that's local
those are people that ensure huge
commercials
tv series and big movies and then
there's another one
which does small stuff we went with the
big one
and we took our camera list so our
camera and optics list
from kerner camera we took our gear list
from pgl
and we sent them to the insurance
company because now they have an exact
document which is what we're insuring so
we're not around
and they say okay it's this much bang
and then they ask you questions like
are you doing pyrotechnics are you doing
stunts are you doing underwater work
are you doing um anything that has a
high vertical
etc and that's all producer things that
they'll get used to when they make more
work
but i would short answer is i would call
a camera house and just
say what are the top three and they'll
tell you if they don't tell you then
they're being weird
or you need to just call somebody who's
nice and then call them
and get the hard truth of how much it
really cost to make something
so what about uh production insurance
for
cast and crew not just equipment sure
what what's that
fall under uh well liability yeah yeah
yeah
so basically you have an umbrella policy
that covers
uh general liability general liability
is anyone who gets hurt or
tries to sue you during a film's
production or afterward
and then you have rental insurance
they call it inland marine etc etc and
then you have
sort of specialty insurance which is if
you're doing big stunts or explosions or
guns
or anything that involves
something where there's a risk to a
person's life or
if you're filming at a location that
could be dangerous you're filming at a
volcano you're filming on a train track
you know um and uh
what i would do is just be super honest
about everything
don't don't lie don't steal a location
you know don't
don't say oh yeah we're going to film in
all these places but we're not going to
tell them
about how we're going to film in this
aqueduct or in this like sewer system
or whatever because someone's going to
fall and and your career
and i got a good education on
uh i got a good education on production
insurance for two reasons one
i paid for my own production insurance
for my first film at 800 bucks
and 800 bucks when you're 22 and have no
job it's a lot of money
and they told me what it was for they
said it covers it covers the camera
because with film you're doing a fight
movie
it's only a three day shoot but it's
worth it totally was and then doing
a ton of ads after that you start to
really respect
the comfort and safety of having a
policy that
protects you and everybody else involved
and then from there you can have
particular agreements
depending on a location or depending on
what is involved in the filming
you'll work with sag on that if it's for
actors you'll work with
a union on that if it's for your crew
they may need to sign
certain documents that limits the
liability of their
ability to go on a location because you
say i want
twice as much protection i want this
policy and i want you to sign a
liability waiver that says you're
willing to do this
so it's really uh it's an interesting
job
as a producer because you're kind of a
lawyer so
um but i would say research the hell out
of it
it's not going to be sexy it's not sexy
at all it's boring
it's like buying insurance for your car
but you will
definitely definitely regret it if you
don't do it
so we bought a year-long policy because
i knew that we were going to
shoot and then pick up in the same
calendar year and it saves people a lot
of money to do that
but most people aren't that organized so
they should get sort of uh
they should get temporary production
insurance which is for a particular
that's why they make their money
because if you say hey my shoe is going
to be five days and you shoot five days
and you don't get everything
you don't have insurance anymore so you
call them back and you pay again
that's how they make all their money but
if you're insured as a production for a
period of time you can amortize it over
over multiple shoots so um
but most people need to kind of get down
the road pretty far before that is
applicable
yeah that's interesting though because
you can save more money it sounds like
doing it that way than having to
just not have to react the policy and
also like
you have a sense of like oh if anything
goes wrong and i gotta reshoot this
in a week or in three months it opens up
as a producer it opens up your schedule
you're not trying to
shoot before your insurance ends right
what is making echo taught you about
yourself
and filmmaking put yourself first then
filmmaking
i think it was the longest
project i've ever done
in my life so i mean definitely
um i don't look at schooling as a
project because it changes every quarter
so to speak
it was this
competition that came out in me
with myself
[Music]
and it was
shattering a lot of naivete about
how hard this would be so
you have to have some very challenging
internal conversations with yourself
when you get disheartened
or when you feel alone in a process
even if you have a great support network
it's very easy to just
shut off it
there's there were rises and falls of
depression that were
uncontrollable because you just
get so exhausted with the process
it taught me how to stop also
inside of my myopic obsessive nature
to finish or to get a moment perfect
it taught me to stop to enough is enough
for a day like if we're cutting we've
been cutting for like 12 hours or
something it's like
stop take a break and
i didn't know that about myself you know
um
taught me a lot about health and taking
care of yourself
before the shoot during and afterward
because you can
you can burn out before you start
shooting you can burn out pre-production
and then you get into production and
you're making the most important
decisions about performance or about
coverage or about
a particular moment that matters and you
don't
have the battery power to keep going and
that didn't really happen to me
but i could feel it a couple of times
where i was like i am so
tired and i wasn't prepared for how
tired
my brain was going to be and
in the end of the day
i think it taught me that
no one gives you anything when you get
to the top of the mountain
like no one gives you a trophy or uh
like a reward or a bottle of champagne
and formula one race
or whatnot you're you usually get to the
top of that mountain
in the dark alone and
you have to figure out that that is
what you want it all you know i think at
the beginning it can be really romantic
that when you finish
it's gonna you're gonna run through a
ribbon in a marathon or something
but it's a lot closer to what i've read
about some mountaineering expeditions or
some summiting
of some peaks where a climber got
somewhere in the dark alone and no one
was there
and um you have to figure out what got
you there
you know a lot of people on the way
giving you support a lot of people in
the way
giving you nourishment a lot of people
in the way
helping you know you didn't get there
alone but sometimes you do
land there alone you finish alone um
and and then i think i also learned that
the affair is over you know i think that
before you make a movie
there's an affair it's like a
romanticized idea
of the work and of um
every part of the process you know
people think editing is easy it's the
opposite
you know people think that doing sound
mix is easy it's the opposite
people think they can kind of get away
with doing a di
on like um you know their computer
i don't agree with that um and
so what happened also for me
was learning that the
love affair with
the idea of making a film was dead
and for a little while it wasn't
replaced with anything
it was just over and that didn't mean i
wanted to stop
doing this it meant that there was an
internal feeling of emptiness
and truth and
at the end of that there was a real
strong light at the tunnel
and there was uh
like a maybe a mature
maybe a stronger sensibility of what
this really takes to do
and so then when i looked at my next
project
i looked at what needed to be fixed i
looked at how the script needed to be
polished and reworked
i looked at the production schedule i
immediately pushed production off by a
certain amount
i needed more time to do this right and
so i suddenly came at the sophomore film
the next film i suddenly came at that
film with a sense of
um realism
not optimism and um
love and not lust you know
and um one of the things i also learned
was that i have a very
um incredible wife
you know and our relationship went from
you know
having lots of passion and having lots
of lust and just being so in love with
each other
and then when we got married it became
complicated and super interesting
and better and richer and and the fabric
of everything
became stronger and as very synonymous
with my breath
my metaphor about the affair of making a
movie is over
and it becomes better and more
interesting i don't think you can rush
that
because i went through a lot of pain to
go from
feeling the affair to being in love with
this craft more than i ever have but i
had to go through
all of the darkness first and not
pretend
like i had done it before i think some
filmmakers
including myself years ago maybe
had a sense of feeling like i could do
it and it wouldn't be hard
and it's a different journey so
i learned how to tell myself the truth
more
yeah i don't remember the other question
wow i don't know if if it can top that
i'm just what did um
making echo teach you about filmmaking
oh yeah sure
sure uh what did echo what did making
echo teach me about filmmaking yeah
um
it was a
opportunity to see strengths and
weaknesses
under a microscope right these are the
things i thought i was good at
these are the things i think i needed to
work on and when you take the duration
of your material
and when you take the audience's
investment in the material right
okay so they were going to be invested
in a 30-second ad or 60-second ad or
what have you right okay
so how much of that day is it taking how
much are they invested in watching this
content
okay so that's what that is and then
over here it's like they're gonna buy a
ticket to your movie and give you two
hours of their life
in a place that's not in their house and
that is a completely different
invitation
so it taught me a lot about the reality
of
okay this muscle this strength is solid
this is good i can keep improving that
and i'm going to challenge myself to do
that on the next movie and here's how
um and then the the
opposite's true which is i feel like
this aspect of the story or the script
needed work
and it never got the right amount of
work and
it pisses me off but it didn't and
it got finished and it's done
so it's like you can noodle with it
forever and you never
ever finish it or you finish it and you
say i gotta really be honest with myself
about
that's gotta get fixed next time
it taught me a lot about as a
as a director it taught me a lot about
people
uh taught me a lot about um
expectations and morale
i was reminded just before
this save my ass by the way i was
reminded just before we started filming
like a week before
uh my dad says you're the captain of the
ship
and i was like of course you know like
thank you and he goes i didn't mean it
like that
i meant it like you're the captain of
the ship
you are the captain of the ship things
go right you're the captain of the ship
if things go wrong
you're the captain of the ship and
after four or five days um it became
super clear
that i needed to adapt
my leadership style to the team not
because they needed me to or asked me to
but because i was paying attention to
being the captain of the ship
and whether that was to
um make sure to every day
in the morning say good morning to every
person on the team
and at the end of the day tell every
person on a team great day
which i did do and i had already really
been doing that but it wasn't hyper
diligent
it wasn't as focused around you know
what they're
working so hard every day and we're only
20 in or 15
or whatever it was and okay great so
that i needed i needed to be a better
leader
and um and then it also
uh taught me a lot about editorial
i learned that i'm used to assembling
and cutting while i'm going
on ads and we didn't have that strategy
on this film
and we are changing it on the next film
so
for example we shoot uh you know we
shoot material i look at some dailies
but i don't make editorial decisions the
editor's not on set working
and then when we're done and we're in
the can i look at everything
for a period of four weeks or whatever
and then we start assembling
i learned that that process was super
inefficient and
the result of that process was that or
the reason why it happened
was because we were working so fast
and so hard every day there wasn't time
to review material in earnest
and so that's going to change on the
next film the next film we're going to
cut concurrently with the production
um i read a lot about how that's done
i talked to a bunch of editors in
hollywood about how they do it
i followed the process or you know
really drilled in on the process the way
they cut munich
spielberg's film they they cut it
concurrently
and they were able to have a strong
assembly of the cat within i believe a
few
weeks after production and it also
creates an efficiency in any pickups and
etc so probably one of the biggest
lessons i learned was about
editorial and the last thing i really
really learned about was
my passion for
meticulous cinematography
and very specific color grade work in
the di
is equal to my
level of passion for sound design in the
mix
you know i had had a lot of experience
in a di
for commercials but the mix on
commercials
is really quick they do it in a day it's
done you're not even usually there
and on a film the mix along with foley
and design and dialogue cleanup and
looping and stuff
you know this takes months and months to
do and
i fell in love with the sound design
process i fell in love with
the final mix making this weighted ratio
decisions on the audience's experience
from a sound perspective and that was
i've never had that experience before
so that was really exciting so um
yeah i'm sure my answer to this question
could be like two hours long
let's say we brought you in to address a
room of let's say 20 students
i don't know and they're about to make
uh their first feature
they've already made a few shorts sure
what are you telling them
what's your advice to them um have they
written their scripts
let's say half of them have half of them
have
um okay i'll answer
half of your question first okay and
then i'll ask you another question
um for the half that haven't written
them yet
i would say
write what you can shoot
and shoot what you can cut and
cut what you can finish because
uh from my experience i started writing
ideas and then scripts that were um
weren't in the realm of possibility of
making or producing
so i didn't waste time my approach was
to write
material that i wanted to see and i
wanted to make
and that's that's great if you're
writing
scripts on spec but not if you're going
to write a script to make a film
right which you can shoot and so if you
can shoot it
then you better be able to cut it so
don't
don't try to shoot an action movie if
you can't cut an action movie
because the last part will be true which
is you won't finish it
the only reason i have a career is
because i finished a film
first and then i became more and more
and more ambitious
finishing things along the way and i was
talking to a friend of mine the other
day and he said 70
of all features are not finished
and so i think it's very hard when
you tell a film student or a fan of film
that hey man you know your kung fu
action movie
is not going to happen right now you
should do
a bank heist movie that ends in a diner
and don't show the heist or something
like that so it's a matter of
shoot or write which you can shoot and
then finish it and make sure it's done
and then it will be a tool
it will be a it will be a calling card
for you to move forward
um but nobody cares about your career if
you can't finish anything
second question or the second half of
the group
i would say if their scripts are done
uh are they financed do they have
capital do they have investors
is the process they're in pre-production
or is the process they're in financing
okay let's suppose most of them will be
either
getting money from family and friends
putting it on a credit card
or they're going to some will try their
attempt at crowdfunding it doesn't mean
they will be successful yeah
um if they're at a stage where they're
going to um
[Music]
get film financing um
i would sit down and
have a conversation with yourself or
with your team
depending on how you how you're working
if you're working with a team of
producers and you guys are all a unit
well then talk about it together if
you're not if you're just some rogue
dude or a gal
and you're just gonna do this like
robert rodriguez uh then just have this
conversation with yourself
and that is what are you gonna do with
the film
it has to have a purpose it has to have
an audience so you have to think okay
i'm gonna make this film
and i'm gonna submit it to sundance or
i'm gonna make this film and i'm gonna
submit it to a horror film festival
or i'm gonna make this film and i'm
gonna use it
to go get an advertising commercial
director job
has to have a purpose because before you
can figure out
how much an investment in this project
is worth it has to have a value
and the value has to be its goal right
so its goal is to
i want it to festival and who knows what
will happen okay great well when you
talk to people about
helping you that's your vision
your vision is i'm gonna tell you about
two people in a canoe
in this horror movie it's like no no
they want to hear about what you're
gonna do with it when it's done
they don't care about they don't really
care about how you're gonna make it
they really don't because they're not
you
also if you know what you're going to do
with it
then you can justify something like
putting it on your credit card
which i would not advise to anyone i
know someone who did that
years ago she went into 60 000 of debt
credit card wise the movie went nowhere
she was paying that off for 10 years
and she didn't have a goal with the film
which is one of her challenges
and also it just sort of
it it became a pet project a vanity
project instead of a project she could
really stand behind
if you're using someone else's money
there's also a sense of duty
to finish so if you are asking for
family and friends and stuff like that
to help you
if they do give you the money there's a
sense of debt which is good
to them crowdfunding i don't know
anything about that
i don't know i have no idea how that
really works
my guess is the only way you get
crowdfunding is if you have
a flash teaser or flash trailer or
something that
can tell a stranger that
their money should be in your pocket
i know people have done it before i've
seen some teasers for it
you know success is probably all over
the map about it
but but yeah i would i would definitely
say the first thing is to figure out
what they're going to do with the
film so that it legitimizes the
investment and doesn't become a vanity
project
and then the last thing i would say to a
group full of filmmakers who's about to
start
is communication
is it can be really hard
if it's your art can be really hard if
it's your
work but if you're working with the
right
people they're all going to make your
vision
a reality don't be a diva
we've all met those people we've all met
the people who either
went to usc film school or they went to
a filmmaking class on a weekend and they
are a diva no one wants to work for you
if you're a diva zero people want to
work for you
and even less people want to work for
you day two
so you have to figure out hey
i'm in pre-production hey i got some
money hey i got
really good insurance and i have really
good people
really good people and those are the
people that work super duper hard
i know people who are very successful
who still work on no money projects all
the time
if they like the people and
chances are that everyone i'm talking to
is in that boat
so i would spend time getting to know
the people who are on your crew
really well you know i wouldn't put
director on your chair
people put director on their chair and
it's like that's so stupid
um years ago years ago a woman i was
dating her mother bought me a director's
chair and she was very wealthy person
and she had an embroidered it said
director
and i have my name on it and i put it in
storage and now it's gone
i never ever took it on a set ever
because one
if you're a good director you're not
sitting in that chair ever
and two nobody cares
the last thing i would tell people who
want to have a long future
in the business is
find out what the people at your camera
house
and your grip and electric house and
your truck rental house and
maybe the people who do film permits
find out what they like to drink
and buy it
i don't know how many bottles of scotch
or champagne or
cubes of beer i've bought for people who
never forgot that hey this is the guy
who's always grateful for my help right
and um that's what matters you know
especially if you're underfunded
is that you really care about all the
people around you and
all the people that get to decide if you
get to make your film
so yeah and the one last curveball would
be
somebody who wants to make a feature
they don't have any plans to do anything
with it they just want the experience
so and it's not really a vanity project
in that they're not totally casting
themselves they just want to know what
it's like
from start to finish to make a film
and what's the question exactly question
is what what are their set of parameters
how are they doing it differently
or is it all the same it doesn't really
matter
i think that i have
met
no one in my life who's wealthy enough
to make a movie by themselves for fun
and have no goal the only person i can
think of in history is like howard
hughes
and so i i don't think i would be able
to give any advice to
a person who had a trust fund and
thought it would be fun to make a film
because
even if they have a lot of money and
time
and they're creative and even if they're
super nice
they're still going to be engaging with
a lot of other people on their crew
they're going to be renting things in
order to make this experience possible
and all of the um
all of the parameters around respect and
all the parameters around
gratitude apply to them anyway
the only caution i would give someone
who's doing it for fun
is is probably easy for you to waste
other people's time
and i learned i think it was the first
couple of weeks i was in la
i learned how long it took to get from
one place to another
right and i was late to a couple
meetings i wasted a couple of people's
time
and they made it super clear to never do
that again so
i hope that this rich fictional phantom
person who's making a movie for fun
pays people a lot of money and doesn't
waste their time yeah